Oh Gott, kurz gucken, ob Teams nicht wieder an den Audio-Settings rumgestellt hat.
Wir kennen Teams, Teams steht immer an den Audio-Settings.
Natürlich, was?
War ja klar.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das soll.
Jedes Mal der gleiche Kacke, Alter, du kannst das Teams nicht abgewöhnen.
So, Leute, ich habe zum ersten Mal so richtig was Sinnvolles mit meinem 3D-Drucker gemacht gestern.
Ne, vorgestern.
Und zwar, ich habe mir so einen Winkel ausgedruckt, um eine Holzplatte an die Wand machen zu können.
Und ich habe mir eine Mounting-Plate für meinen Access-Point ausgedruckt.
Mal hier, Dingy-Wars.
Nein, nein, wie kein Nano-Leaf.
Guckt, so eine Platte habe ich mir ausgedruckt, dass ich meinen Access-Point an die Decke hängen kann.
Wobei ich ihn nicht an die Decke hängen kann.
Weil ich dachte mir, so eine Decke hält es wahrscheinlich nicht so gut aus.
Das ist ja so eine dünne Gips-Decke.
Deswegen habe ich mir noch so einen Mounting-Winkel für ein Brett an der Wand ausgedruckt.
Ja, zumindest kann man da seinen Access-Point mounten.
Aber natürlich, wow, Alter, was ist das für Geruckel?
Null weh.
Nachdem das erste, was passiert ist, dass diese Dinger hier abgebrochen sind.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Weil ich habe dann diese Inserts reingeschmolzen.
Die haben wir uns hier ja schon im Stream angeguckt.
Ich habe so Inserts, die man reinschmelzen kann, in 3D gedrucktes Zeug.
Und dann kannst du Metallschrauben reinschrauben.
Und das habe ich ausgedruckt.
Und ich muss sagen, das hängt jetzt an der Wand.
Ich habe ein Foto gemacht, aber ich kann euch das Foto gerade nicht zeigen.
Weil ich habe es auf dem Handy und ich weiß nicht, wie ich das gescheit rüberkriege.
Ohne Upload und Download und Geschiss.
Das funktioniert tatsächlich erstaunlich gut.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Mounting.
Mounting-Platte.
An das Brett.
X-Point an die Platte gehängt.
Und wunderbar.
Pog.
Dibulon, danke schön.
29 Monate Hyper-Subscription hier.
Oh, falscher Knopf.
Falscher Knopf.
Hyper-Subscriber.
Das wollte ich eigentlich.
Team Sound, das sind alle gleich Instant.
Vogue.
Sind die dann.
Ah ja.
Ist doch früh.
Ist doch vor 9, Leute.
Aber so früh bin ich normalerweise nie on, oder?
Ich bin schon seit 8 oder so am Rechner.
Hab ein bisschen rumgeklickt.
Schon ein paar Videos aufgemacht, was wir uns dann angucken können.
Natürlich der übliche Level-Capture-Bait muss auch sein.
Leute, ich muss euch sagen, der Eurovision Song Contest ging mir so am Arsch vorbei.
Ich kann das immer nicht verstehen, dass da Leute jedes Jahr sich diesen Krempel echt angucken.
Belangloser könnte es kaum sein.
Aber Twitter, ich habe ja den Fehler gemacht.
Ich weiß, ich hätte es gar nicht mitbekommen.
Hätte ich nicht die Twitter-Trends mal just for fun, ich muss ja immer zum Beispiel, ich kann es teilweise nicht lassen,
die Twitter-Trends doch mir mal auf Deutsch angeguckt.
Da habe ich mitbekommen, dass dieser Krempel wieder ist.
Ich habe auch gelesen, wir sind letzter geworden, aber es geht mir so massive am Arsch vorbei.
Es gibt wirklich nicht viel, was mich weniger interessiert.
Ah ja.
Oder ansonsten.
Was gibt es bei euch, neues Chat?
Außer, dass ihr noch schlauer geworden seid.
Es geht ja gar nicht anders.
Wisst ihr, mit jedem Sub kollektiv plus plus IQ.
Und wohlgemerkt, es ist plus plus IQ und nicht IQ plus plus, weil wir wissen ja alle, was der Unterschied ist.
Plus plus IQ wird gemacht, bevor die restliche Expression ausgewertet wird und IQ plus plus danach.
Und natürlich ist der Chat davor schlau.
Meistens macht es keinen Unterschied, ob man plus plus davor oder plus plus danach schreibt, aber.
Tja.
Alter.
So.
Ansonsten, lass mal überlegen.
Gab es die Woche noch irgendwelche weiteren spannenden Dinger?
Also ich habe gelesen, irgendein Artikel bei der CT, da können wir uns nachher auch sogar ein Video zu angucken,
dass Windows 11 immer noch kacke ist.
Also ich hatte recht.
Wenn sogar die CT das schreibt.
Gibt es Sturmschäden bei euch?
Katze nicht weggeflogen?
Nö, es gab gar nichts.
Die Bäume haben sich ganz schön gebogen.
Ist aber nichts umgefallen.
Gibt ja auch nicht mal viel zum Umfallen.
Ein Baum vom Nachbar ist irgendwie vor einem Jahr oder so schon umgefallen und hat bei uns den Zaun platt gemacht.
Aber zum Glück nur den Zaun.
Sonst nichts.
Die Katze, die hat ein sehr gutes Gespür dafür.
Wann Scheiß wer da draußen ist und grenzt und setzt sich dann entweder unter das Sofa oder in den Schrank oder sonst wo und versteckt sich.
Wieso ist PHP scheiße?
So scheiße ist PHP doch gar nicht.
Kommt drauf an, was man mit PHP verwendet.
Also wenn man jetzt, sag mal, so Raw PHP macht mit Session Handling und dem ganzen Krempel von Hand, dann ist es scheiße.
Weil die Sprache an sich muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Naja, ist ein bisschen her, dass ich was mit PHP gemacht habe, aber die Sprache an sich war.
Ja, die konnte man schon verwenden, aber so die schönste war es nicht.
Ja, dann ist eklig.
Dann ist eklig.
Die IHK Zwischenprüfung war Monarch S.
Was wollten die?
Es ist eigentlich mittlerweile so, dass die Zwischenprüfung in irgendeiner Art und Weise zur Abschlussnote dabei zählt.
Also bei mir war die Zwischenprüfung einfach nur komplett just for fun.
Die musste man machen, aber es war komplett egal, ob man sie gemacht hat oder nicht.
Ich glaube aber mittlerweile, dass die Zwischenprüfung...
...in irgendeiner Art und Weise mitzählt.
Aber was ab diesem Jahr, ernsthaft, wirklich, das haben die uns damals schon erzählt.
Und damals, also ich habe die Ausbildung 2007 gemacht.
Das haben die uns damals schon erzählt.
Ja, wir haben Glück, bald ist die Zwischenprüfung auch in der Abschlussnote.
Und dann haben die allen Ernstes jetzt 15 Jahre gebraucht von der Ankündigung, dass es bald soweit ist.
Gut, das wundert mich bei der IHK auch nichts mehr.
15 Jahre bei der IHK ist wahrscheinlich morgen.
So.
Mittlerweile heißt sie auch AP.
AP 1, okay, da weiß eh kein Mensch, für was diesen ganzen Abkürzungskram steht.
Game Up, danke für 19 Monate Hyper-Subscription hier.
Habe ich ihn eigentlich noch für Krempel auf?
Was?
Mein PC von 2017?
Ne, den brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Aber den kann man mal auflassen, den brauchen wir.
Äh, Dice Whip, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Ja, ja, ja, alles klar.
Warum habe ich Chip auf?
Wer macht denn Chip freiwillig aus?
Das Strukturizer.
Nein, alles zumachen.
Ne, bis ich Tabs schließen.
Äh, Tabs schließen.
Tabs schließen.
Ja, das habe ich übrigens mittlerweile bei mir daheim laufen, falls sich das einer fragt.
Hatten wir uns da angeguckt.
Meine Wetterstation ist jetzt komplett über Home Assistant erreichbar.
Soll ich euch mal einen Screenshot zeigen?
Ich zeige euch mal einen Screenshot.
Deck.
Postchamp.
Okay, das Fenster ist ein bisschen zu klein.
Ist nicht ausgeschrieben, aber es passt schon.
So sieht meine Wetterstation, so sieht meine Wetterstation Daten jetzt im Home Assistant aus.
Außen Tempo.
Außentemperatur.
Sowohl, sowohl richtige Außentemperatur, als auch die gefühlte Außentemperatur.
Das macht ja irgendwie anhand des Windes fest oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber es unterscheidet sich manchmal.
Ähm, ja, ja.
Das ist der Unterschied.
Das ist das, was dir die Wetterberichte auch, also die Wettervorhersage auch immer erzählt.
Und zwar, wenn es beispielsweise 12, 13 Grad draußen ist, aber es ist nass und es regnet.
Äh, es hat geregnet.
Und es bläst viel Wind.
Dann ist die gefühlte Temperatur deutlich unter der eigentlichen Außentemperatur.
Tatsächlich ganz sinnvolle Geschichte hier.
So.
Äh, Wind.
Wind ist gerade nicht vorhanden.
Deswegen ist gefühlte Außentemperatur ziemlich gleich.
Äh, Regen gibt's auch gerade nicht.
Und Feinstaub ist tatsächlich ziemlich gering.
Ich hab gerade 69 Zuschauer.
Gatschi Bass.
Quasi kaum Feinstaub.
Aber heute ist Sonntag und fährt auch keiner draußen rum und sonst was.
So sieht's aus, aber das stimmt gar nicht für heute.
Okay.
Äh, macht aber nix.
Weiß eh nicht, ob da irgendjemand reinguckt noch.
Doch.
Aber es ist schön, dass jeder schreibt, wobei doch, da gucken Leute rein.
Ich seh das Kommando öfters mal.
Hype Train is close.
Ah, verpasst.
Gibt, Hype Train.
Gibt Schlimmeres.
Ganze, Jeff braucht nicht noch, äh, neues Raumschiff.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, und ansonsten gibt's eigentlich die Woche nicht sonderlich viel Spannendes, glaube ich.
Oder war, glaube ich, nicht sonderlich viel Spannendes.
Ich hab meinen Einkaufs-Stream immer noch nicht beendet, fällt mir ein.
Wir haben die Hälfte von dem, was wir brauchen erst.
Aber machen wir irgendwann die Tage fertig.
Ich überleg grad.
War die Woche irgendwas Spannendes, wo ich jetzt grad nicht dran denke?
Mal kurz, mal kurz drüber, drüber scrollen.
Äh, haben die nicht immer nur Wochenzusammenfassungen oder sowas?
Es war, glaube ich, die Woche erstaunlich wenig.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich wieder extrem viel gemietet, weil, weil...
Weil Mieten ja mittlerweile das ist, wofür man bezahlt wird.
Das ist teilweise echt lustig.
Wenn man sich überlegt, eigentlich, ja, wird man da bezahlt dafür, dass man Ahnung von, äh, wie wird's meine Oma sagen, Computerzeug hat.
Dass man, dass man, dass man sich ganz gut mit Computer auskennt.
Würde man eigentlich vermuten.
Aber, mittlerweile ist es so, dass 50, mindestens 50 Prozent, eigentlich von jeder x-beliebigen 0815,
ahnungslosen Personen ausgeführt werden könnte.
Also, im Prinzip bezahlen die mich für was, was ich gar nicht mache, weil ich viel zu viel mieten muss.
Also, also, eigentlich bräuchte man mich vom Know-how gar nicht, sondern mich in Person von, von Mieten vielleicht.
Also, man könnte auch jemand anderes für mich mieten lassen und dann könnte ich mehr Sachen machen, auf die ich Bock hab.
Und, äh, die Firma wird auch mehr für ihr Geld kriegen, aber das wollen sie nicht.
Hast du die API von, von...
Ja, hab ich, das funktioniert mittlerweile.
Ich lad euch jetzt, ich lad euch das, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich das Bild nicht doch irgendwie hochladen kann.
Kennt jemand einen guten Image-Haus, der da nicht Image, Image, äh, uuuh, Dingsbums, im, im, im, imigure oder so ist?
Ich lad's einfach.
Choose Image, Photo Library, ich zeig euch, ich zeig euch die Bilder mal.
Bockchamp, Bockchamp-Bilder zeig ich euch.
Ad, Moment, zeig ich, zeig ich, ich zeig euch das, wenn der, wenn der Upload funktioniert.
Ich lade das gerade auf irgendeine Image, Image-Seite hoch hier, okay, Moment.
Äh...
Post, Post, Image.
So.
Ich hab mich mal die Bilder von meinem Access-Point hochgeladen, mit dem 3D, mit dem 3D gedruckten Frame.
Ähm, der ist jetzt im Einsatz, also guckt mal.
Das ist das, was ich mein, ich hab, ich hatte Angst, dass meine Decke das nicht aushält.
Ja, und bevor jetzt einer kommt, das Brett ist nicht richtig abgeschnitten, ich weiß, das hab ich nicht abgeschnitten.
Ähm...
Das hatte ich noch, rumliegen.
Das ist von irgendwas, fragt man aus der Küche oder so, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, ich hab die Mounting-Plate ausgedruckt, muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Tatsächlich, ganz, ganz praktisch.
Ähm, ich hab diese Platte ausgedruckt, zum Mounten.
Und damit der Access-Point unten dran hält, hab ich Inserts reingeschmolzen mit dem Lötkolben.
Das sind so, so hier, Threaded Inserts, irgendwie so heißt der Kram.
Das da, das ist, ähm, das sind Metall.
Dinger, hier sieht man's, guck, so sieht das aus.
Das sind so Metalldinger, die schmilzt man mit dem Lötkolben in 3D-gedruckten, äh, in 3D-gedruckte Plastik rein.
Und dann kann man da Schrauben reinschrauben.
Und die halten tatsächlich, da würde das gar nicht denken, aber, guck, so.
Warum sollte ich die Decke nicht haben, weil das dünnes Gips ist?
Guck mal, du schmilzt das da rein.
Ob du da Löcher drunter machst oder nicht, ist eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Du schmilzt das da rein.
So, und dann lässt du, lässt du das mal 2-3 Minuten abkühlen, dann hast du ein Gewinde in deinem 3D-Druck drin.
So.
Und so hab ich das hier auch gemacht.
Ich hab ein Gewinde in meinem...
NKS, Alter.
Was für eine Auflösung das iPhone hat, das fällt mir immer, immer erst dann wieder auf.
Ähm, ich hab jetzt ein Gewinde in meinem 3D-Druck drin, woran ich dann zwei, wo, wo ich zwei Schrauben reingedreht hab.
So.
Und daran kann man jetzt den Access-Point hängen.
Ach ja, das andere hab ich auch aus dem 3D-Drucker.
Hier so komische Winkel für das Brett.
Hält alles bombenfest.
So, und dann hab ich den Access-Point da unten dran gehängt.
Kann man in Plastik Gewinde schneiden?
Ja, das ist das, was ich grad gezeigt hab.
Du nimmst so, so fertige Metalldinger und schmilzt die mit dem Lötkolben in dein 3D-gedrucktes, äh, Objekt rein.
Und da kannst du dann Schrauben reindrehen.
Und das ist richtig.
Schraubenreinfest.
Ach so.
Ja, du kannst Schrauben reinmachen in 3D-gedrucktes Zeug, aber nach ein bisschen Schrauben, also das ist nicht sonderlich, äh, ja, schön.
Also du könntest das wahrscheinlich gut machen, wenn du größere, dickere Schrauben nimmst, aber die meisten Modelle haben dafür gar keinen Platz, um irgendwie sonderlich dicke Schrauben zu nehmen.
Ja, du kannst in 3D-gedruckte Sachen reinschrauben, aber, also, sonderlich haltbar ist das nicht.
Das mag zwar halten, wenn du es eins, maximal zweimal...
Öffnest oder so.
Aber spätestens beim dritten Mal rein- und rausschrauben ist das ausge...
Das ist nix.
Also so ist, so ist deutlich, deutlich besser.
Und das ist wirklich fest.
Also, da kannst du dich fast dranhängen.
Also das ist wirklich fest.
Das würde ich gar...
Das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Also, nicht da dranhängen, aber hier an diese D...
Also das ist wirklich fest.
Da wird man gar nicht von ausgehen.
Also das reicht man nicht einfach so raus.
Kiff, danke schön für den Sub.
So, und dann hab ich den Access Point genommen.
Und hab den einfach da unten drangehängt.
Und...
Fertig.
Das ist jetzt irgendwie andere Auflösung, weil man weiß es nicht genau.
So, und dann hab ich einfach den Access Point genommen und unten drangehängt.
Ich hab das Kabel dann noch so an die Wand gemacht.
Und gut ist.
So.
Und jetzt hängt der Access Point...
Drüben, kopfüber, unter der Decke.
So wie das sein muss.
Die Dinger sind nämlich eigentlich für Ceiling Mount...
Mounted gedacht.
Und...
Ich kann die nicht gescheit an das Ceiling mounten, weil meine Decke...
Man sieht es hier teilweise.
Das ist ganz dünnes Gips.
Da hatte ich Schiss, das dran zu...
Zu machen.
Der ist der Access Point riesig.
Beides bisschen.
Also das täuscht schon.
Weil, ich mein, guck mal, hier hinten siehst du...
Hier siehst du quasi das letzte Drittel von der Tür.
Das letzte Drittel von der Tür ist ungefähr so lang wie der Access Point.
Ja, oder das letzte Viertel von der Tür.
Ist ungefähr so lang wie der Access Point.
Also, das täuscht, aber der Access Point ist jetzt auch nicht der allerkleinste.
Also das ist ein...
Weiß nicht, ob man das irgendwie mit...
Mit der Größe...
Irgendwie vergleichen kann.
Ob es da irgendwas Gescheites gibt.
Also das ist...
Weiß nicht, ob man die Abmaße da sieht.
Das ist, by the way, falsch.
Das sieht überhaupt nicht so aus.
Ähm...
Ja.
Ja, das sind die Kleinen.
Ja, die Kleinen, die sind 13...
13 Zentimeter.
Und der ist doch schon eine ganze Ecke größer.
Ja, der ist...
Der ist relativ fett.
Aber, wisst ihr, was das Gute ist?
Ich hab jetzt...
Meine vier Unify Access Points abgefüllt.
Ich hatte ja im Keller, im ersten Stock, im Erdgeschoss und für die Terrasse draußen ein Unify Access Point.
Und...
Oben, erstes Bild.
Ah ja, tatsächlich, null.
Ja, 22 Zentimeter mal 22 Zentimeter.
Also ist ganz schöner...
Chonker.
Als Access Point.
Pepo Fett Access Point.
Also der ist schon ordentlich.
Aber, was halt wirklich nice ist...
Das Teil kann jetzt komplett...
Sag mal.
Ich hab jetzt vier Unify Access Points abgeschaltet.
Und ich hab jetzt nur noch ein Access Point stehen.
Der ist oben im Wohnzimmer.
Also im ersten Stock im Wohnzimmer.
So weit, wie es geht zum Flur.
Das heißt, es ist die zentralste Position, wo ich ohne Probleme drankomme.
Und der versorgt Geräte im Keller, im Erdgeschoss, im ersten Stock, theoretisch im Dach, bis runter.
Auf die Terrasse.
Und fast zum Eingang vom Garten.
Ein Access Point.
Wo ich vorher vier Unify Access Points hatte.
Also da kann ich mich echt nicht beschweren.
Einzig der Empfang.
Nicht nur Strom sparen.
Der ist auch von den Features her deutlich besser.
Und wenn du näher dran bist, ist er auch noch schneller.
Obwohl er eine Generation alt ist.
Das einzige Teil, was etwas Verbindungsprobleme hat.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob es noch erreichbar ist.
Ich weiß sogar, die IP-Chance ist noch erreichbar.
Sehr...
Uh, uh, Wifi-Verbindung.
MonkaS.
Ah.
Nein, ich benutze keinen Controller.
Also das einzige Teil von meinen WLAN-Geräten, was irgendwie Verbindungsprobleme hat.
Ist im Keller.
Halb unter der Heizung.
Hinter der Heizung, nicht unter der Heizung.
Hinter der Heizung.
Eine Steuerung für...
So einen Wasserhahn.
Das hat auch die beschissenste Position.
Und das verliert manchmal die Verbindung.
Ihr habt es ja gerade gesehen.
Also manchmal ist das Gerät der Meinung, no pass.
Kein Bock.
Das legt sich aber in ein paar Minuten wieder.
Dann geht es.
Das ist natürlich kacke.
Und deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, entweder mal gucken, ob ich an den Tasmota-Settings ein bisschen rumbauen kann.
Alternativ muss ich vielleicht den Access-Point...
Ähm.
...auch noch runterstellen.
Unten ins Wohnzimmer.
Wobei das meine weniger bevorzugte Variante ist.
Nein, ich benutze nicht den Controller, das ist unleashed.
Nein, das ist kein MikroTik.
Ähm.
Nein.
Äh, ich habe das, was standardmäßig eingestellt ist.
Aber, dass das Gerät nicht erreichbar ist, liegt wahrscheinlich nicht an der Sendeleistung irgendwie des Access-Points, sondern wahrscheinlich daran,
dass der, äh,
der ESP-2866 im Keller nicht genug überträgt, übertragen, also selbst nicht genug auf die Reihe bekommt und der mit Abstand die beschissenste Position im ganzen Haus hat.
Also der ist quasi halb hinter einer dicken Metall, äh, Box, nämlich der Heizung.
Relativ weit, also er ist maximal weit weg durch maximal weit Wände und halb hinter einer Metallbox, deswegen mag das nicht.
Also deswegen muss ich den vielleicht tatsächlich nochmal umpositionieren.
Ähm.
Wobei ich darauf echt keinen Bock habe.
Naja.
Aber, was machst du nicht alles?
Zumindest eine Sache ist auch schön, wenn man die Sachen mit einem Access-Point macht.
Ich mache keinen Repeater im Keller.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das muss alles, das muss alles mit einem Access-Point abgefackelt werden.
Repeater kommen ja nicht ins Haus.
Doch Müll.
Könnte man machen, könnte man machen.
Aber das ist wirklich die, ja.
Ja, keine Ahnung, also unerwünschteste Sache.
Ich mein, ich hab sogar ein Raspberry Pi angeschlossen, im Keller, per Kabel.
Was bedeutet, ich könnte ohne Probleme im Keller da unten, ähm, was, repeaten oder.
Aber, ne, ne, ne, ne, will ich nicht.
Ne.
Dann stell ich das Ding lieber, lieber in, in, unten ins Wohnzimmer oder so.
Ein Vorteil von einem Access-Point ist natürlich auch,
dass man,
keine probleme mit irgendwelchen roaming hat das ist mittlerweile viel besser als früher
aber du hast halt keine probleme das was abbricht weil es ist immer der gleiche access point gut wie dem auch sei
genug über den access point erzählt das ding ist wirklich nice also das ist das hat sich gelohnt es waren tatsächlich mal gut investierte
270 euro auf ebay und ich habe gesehen dass es aktuell tatsächlich sogar
weil letztens jemand gefragt hat relativ günstig also nicht so was hier relativ günstig
welche gibt
und man kann die dinger wenn man will ich also ich würde bevorzugen ist irgendwo aus eu zu bestellen
aber man kann auch die us dinger verwenden weil man kann die
country anlocken aber wie gesagt repeater habe ich habe ich
überhaupt keinen bock drauf
wie gesagt ich glaube das liegt nicht daran dass der access point zu schlecht ist weil alles andere im keller bekommt auch ganz gut empfangen
das liegt glaube ich eher am esp 266
dass der nicht genug zurück schicken kann
bekommen wird er die signale von max point ich hab mal ein paar ich habe bei der gelegenheit gesehen es gibt sogar
Im apple store es gibt sogar als app
war mir so gar nicht klar
habe ich habe ich mal ordentliche
bandbreiten tests gemacht ich habe das ding einfach auf fünf minuten eingestellt und wenn ich am access point steht habe ich ungefähr 300 mbit
350 mbit
Maximal
Und wenn ich dann
Runter laufe, die Treppe, Terrasse
Sonst wieder geht es natürlich runter
Und ich kriege bis zum Garteneingang
Empfang mit
7, 8 Mbit, 11, 12 teilweise
Aber dann ist Schluss
Was aber auch reicht, ich brauche im Garten kein WLAN
Overrated, Chebaded, Outdated
So, okay Leute
Also was gucken wir uns jetzt an
Zeigt mal her
Ich würde sagen, wir lassen uns erstmal Level Cap Chebaden
Gucken wir dann
Was habe ich hier alles für einen Krempel aufgemacht
Alter, hör mal auf
Ich würde mich Level Cap Chebaden lassen
Und wir müssen
Wir machen mal kurz hier die ganzen
Vorschau Dinge dazu
YouTube, letzte Chance was zu empfehlen
He probably uninstalled this game after this
Zeigt her
Ah, BO1
Oh
Okay, das ist wirklich
Lucky as fuck gewesen
Dass er das getroffen hat
Äh
Also das ist, das kommt nicht, das kam in dem Game nicht oft vor
Und hat auch noch Sticky dran
Und dann hat er doppelt zwei Leute auch noch gekillt
Ja, kommt vor
Aber sehr selten
Warum sind die Ubiquity Teile rausgeflogen bei dir
Hat mehrere Gründe
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da ein Command für haben
Haben wir da ein Command für
Weiß nicht, zumindest
Ähm, also
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn
Mir hat einiges nicht gefallen
Aber
Das, was für mich
Der ausschlaggebende Punkt letztendlich war
Oder was alleine schon der ausschlaggebende Punkt wäre
Unabhängig von den anderen Sachen, die mir nicht gefallen haben
Dass
Äh, Unify
Seit Jahren
Kein Bock hat
Zu implementieren, dass man unterschiedliche Passwörter
Pro Gerät vergeben kann
Und ich rede nicht von
WPA Enterprise
Ja, sondern dass man normale WLAN Passwörter
Pro Gerät vergeben kann
Das finde ich
Äußerst nützlich
Gerade wenn man viele IoT Geräte hat, die man auch mal wegschmeißen will
Weil ansonsten
Legt das WLAN Passwort quasi mit dem Gerät
Im Müll
Vorausgesetzt man kann es nicht mehr überflaschen
Und selbst dann weiß ich nicht, ob das die Geräte
Alles auch richtig löschen oder so
Also ich wollte unbedingt
Passwörter pro Geräte
Das können die meisten WLAN Hersteller
Die, sagen wir mal so
Ein bisschen im teureren Segment sind alle
Mittlerweile kann es sogar TP-Link
Wie die meisten WLAN Hersteller, die, sagen wir mal so ein bisschen im teureren Segment sind alle, mittlerweile kann es sogar TP-Link
Wie die meisten WLAN Hersteller, die ein bisschen im teureren Segment sind alle, mittlerweile kann es sogar TP-Link
und ich hatte jetzt die Auswahl, entweder
ich upgrade
mein Ubiquiti Zeug mal auf
mindestens mal WiFi 5, 6
weil da waren ja teilweise noch richtig
da war noch der erste AC Pro und so
dabei, äh, nicht dass es
zu langsam gewesen wäre, aber ich hätte mal
eh was upgraden müssen, da hab ich mir gedacht, bei der Gelegenheit
was war's, schmeiß den Scheiß raus
kauf dir irgendwas ordentliches von Ebay und gut
ist zwar eine Generation älter
macht aber nix, kann immer noch mehr
und ist immer noch schneller
kostet aber auch ein Access Point
auf Ebay noch mehr als ein neuer
Unify Access Point, ich mein, wenn man sich mal die
neuen
Unify 6 Dinge ankostet, die kosten
200 Euro irgendwie das, den Dreh
und ich hab 270, 260 Euro
bezahlt für einen Access Point von denen
also nicht von denen, von dem neuen Hersteller
äh, 270 Euro
auf Ebay gebraucht, letzte
Generation, also
neu kosten die deutlich mehr, würde ich auch
keiner empfehlen, sich das Ding neu zu kaufen
viel zu übertrieben, ich geb doch keine
1300 Euro für einen Access Point aus
dann kauf ich lieber Generation
ähm, Generation älter
und dann ist gut, nein, macht's nicht
das wäre so, das wäre
so, wenn du
das mit Unify machen würdest
mit Unify könntest du mehrere SSIDs
aufmachen, könntest mehrere
SSIDs mit unterschiedlichen Passwörtern aufmachen, aber
maximal glaub ich auch nur 4 pro Access Point
das ist Müll und das ist für die
Signale wirklich nicht gut, ne, was die machen
ist
also implementieren alle Hersteller
äh, ein bisschen anders
äh, was die machen ist, äh, das
auf einer SSID
letztendlich ist das irgendeine
Kombination aus, ähm
äh, ja, ich weiß es gar nicht genau
irgendwie eine Kombination aus Sachen
in der Access Point Firmware
die halt bei der, bei der, äh, Einwahl
vom Gerät checkt, ist das das richtige Passwort
das muss dann halt gucken, ok
ist das einer der Keys und nicht der
einzige Netzwerkschlüssel und danach
wird das gelockt an die
MAC-Adresse
aber erst nach dem ersten Mal Login
was nicht schlimm ist, weil
naja, du willst es ja eigentlich nur für dieses eine Gerät
verwenden
und selbst wenn du es wegschmeißt
kannst du ja das Passwort immer noch löschen und dann
kann das Gerät selbst mit der richtigen MAC-Adresse nicht mehr rein
das ist alles auf der gleiche SSID, das ist ja das Gute
das ist quasi
bisschen wie WPA Enterprise ohne dass die Geräte WPA Enterprise
unterstützen müssen
was kein IoT-Gerät kann, es gibt keine IoT-Geräte
oder so gut wie keine
IoT-Geräte
die Äh, WPA Enterprise
wie nennt sich das eigentlich korrekt, heißt das WPA Enterprise, ja
Radius heißt so
naja, ok die 822.1x sowieso, natürlich, alles klar
so, lassen wir uns mal eine Runde Level Cap
Chee, Baten
Yib, Yibaydet, Yibaydet
Auf geht's
auf geht's
off
Das neueste Update erzeugt sehr bequeme Verbesserungen.
Ähm, suggeriert irgendwie, dass Battlefield schon mal bei 1.0 war, Battlefield 2042.
Das ist Preview 4.1 vielleicht, ja.
Also, ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie es ist.
Die Overwatch Alpha damals war von technischer Seite her auf einem bedeutend besseren Level als Battlefield 2042 dreiviertel Jahr nach oder ein halbes Jahr nach Release.
Ja, das ist 0.41 eher.
Natürlich kann man die zwei Spiele jetzt vom Anzahl der Spiele und so nicht gut miteinander verkleinern, aber es sind beides Multiplayer-Spiele.
Und schon die Overwatch Alpha damals, die war so weich und hat sich auch netcode-technisch super gespielt.
Da war gar nichts an Problemen.
Aber ansonsten, äh, egal.
Ich will mich jetzt nicht zu sehr über Overwatch auslassen.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was die zwei in Overwatch 2 rechtfertigt, aber okay.
Ja, das ist so, ist wirklich so.
Also, die Battlefield 3 Kampagne fand ich persönlich besser als die Battlefield 4 Kampagne.
Auch wenn die Battlefield 3 Kampagne, ja, du darfst halt nicht, du darfst halt nicht abseits der Hauptwege laufen oder, äh, gar irgendwo, ähm, weiter hin, wo das Spiel sagt, du darfst nicht hin.
Dann ist das nicht sonderlich immersive, die Battlefield 3 Kampagne.
Battlefield 4 fand ich nervig.
Battlefield 4 war das einzige Battlefield im Singleplayer, wo ich so eine Art Motion-Signal...
...Signals bekommen hab, weil das so wackelig war.
Aber, ja, Battlefield 3 und gerade Battlefield 4 sieht auch heute noch verdammt gut aus.
Und die Maps und alles ist einfach dreimal so detailliert.
Vergleich doch mal beispielsweise Siege of Shanghai vs.
Da gab's doch ein, da gab's doch ein schönes Bild.
Da gab's doch ein schönes Bild.
Da gab's doch ein richtig schönes Vergleichsbild.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das hier sehen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das jetzt noch finden.
Zumindest, der hat einen Screenshot gemacht von Siege of Shanghai und Kaleidoskop.
Und du siehst halt auf den ersten Blick, dass Siege of Shanghai laufend an jeder Ecke,
laufend, am laufenden Band Details hat, ja, von Blättern, die rumwehen, zu Zetteln, die an der Wand kleben,
zu Sachen, die wo rumstehen und Kaleidoskop hat einfach nichts.
Gar nichts.
Das ist halt wirklich bitter.
So, wir gucken jetzt das Video an.
Ich hab's fünf Sekunden geschafft, schon drei Minuten zu reden.
Was könnte man eigentlich gerade spielen?
Ja, schwierig, schwierig.
Also es gibt viele Leute, die schwören aktuell auf so die bisschen realistischen Sachen,
sowas wie Squad oder so.
Oder Hell and Loose und solche Dinger.
Kann ich wenig zu sagen, hab ich beides nicht gespielt.
Hab ich mir alles gekauft.
Ich hab alles gekauft auf Steam, aber meine Steam-Bibliothek besteht eh gefühlt zu 80 Prozent aus Dinger,
die ich nicht wirklich gespielt hab.
Ja, YouTube ist nicht so meins.
Rainbow Six Siege, naja, hat jetzt ja mit Battlefield nicht so viel zu tun.
So, also gucken wir uns das Video endlich mal an.
Da muss doch nichts revealed werden, man weiß doch eh schon das Wichtigste.
... ein kontroversiales Update und viel mehr über dieses Wochenende-Gaming.
Was ist denn ein Apex?
Es ist schon einmal schon wieder kontroversial.
Und während es ein kleiner Update war, hat es bemerkenswerte Verbesserungen zu spezifischen Mechaniken gemacht.
Sag mal, der bringt doch in diesen Videos diese Battlefield-News auch nur noch, weil die Leute das memen wollen, oder?
Ansonsten, es interessiert doch wirklich kein...
Darf man's sagen?
Kein Schwanz mehr?
Oder ist das zu sexistisch mittlerweile?
Ich weiß nicht, es interessiert keine Sau mehr, sagen wir mal so, was die da treiben in Battlefield 2042.
Man darf ja noch nicht mal erwarten, dass die Probleme gefixt hätten, die es seit Release gibt.
Beispielsweise die Drohne im Portal-Modus von Bad Company 2, die ist immer noch genauso beknackt wie bei Release.
Das hat keinen interessiert. Ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher, ob es im Portal mittlerweile XP gibt. Ich glaube, das geht mittlerweile.
Zum Beispiel wurde der AI-Sentry-Turret für den Boros-Spezialisten nerft.
Und Angels Möglichkeit, Armor-Pläne durch seine Ammo-Tasche zu geben, wurde nerft.
Und obwohl die meisten von der Community auf diese guten Änderungen zugegeben haben,
wurde eine kontroversere Änderung, die die 128-Spieler-Version von Breakthrough entfernt.
Ja, gut. Das hat zwei Gründe.
Es gibt nicht mehr genug Spieler und bei solchen Spielmodus sieht man's.
Keine Sau spielt das mehr.
Und Breakthrough 128 war von Anfang an der mit Abstand beschissenste Spielmodus von diesem ganzen Ding.
Das war auch die Maps waren blatt.
Folge gestopft mit 128.
Mit 128 Spielern nichts auf der Map drauf, was es spielbar macht mit 128.
Nicht, dass es mit 64 Spielern so viel besser wäre.
Aber kannst es, kannst es ja wirklich spielen.
Das ist 0.41, ja.
Angeblich steht EA zum Verkauf.
Ja.
Na, Activision macht's vor, ne?
Naja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das kann ich mir kaum vorstellen.
Aber das konnte man sich bei Activision auch nicht vorstellen.
Ja, das ist ja normal, gerade so die ultra-hardcore-rosarote-Brille-Battlefield-Fanboys, von denen es immer weniger gibt, aber immer noch ein paar, die finden immer irgendwas, irgendwas Positives dran.
Und wisst ihr, was so ein Argument ist, was mich mega abfuckt, wenn das einer bringt?
Ich weiß, jetzt wird der Chat das zu jeder Gelegenheit sagen.
Und zwar, wenn man, sei es in irgendeinem Forum.
Oder in einem Video.
Oder auf Steam.
Oder sonst wie.
Ja.
Wenn man irgendwas kritisiert.
Ja, wenn man zum Beispiel sagt, es ist eine schlechte Idee gewesen, dass du dir beispielsweise
in Battlefield 2020, 42 Klassen machen kannst, die Snipern und endlich Ammo haben und sich
heilen können.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Ja.
Also wenn du dir irgendwie sagst, warum?
Warum macht man denn sowas?
Das ergibt doch, ergibt doch eigentlich gar keinen Sinn.
Dann kommt als Antwort.
Warum?
Du kannst das gar nicht beurteilen.
Mach es doch selber besser.
Da denke ich mir immer.
Alter.
Painst Champ.
Was ist das denn mal für eine Aussage?
Ich kann doch was schlecht finden und das auch begründet schlecht finden, ohne dass
ich das skilltechnisch from scratch selbst bauen könnte.
Ja.
Das ist wie, wenn ich mir so, ich weiß nicht, in Deutschland stehen wir auf Autovergleiche.
Das ist wie, wenn ich mir ein Auto kaufe und der Sitz ist unbequem.
Ja.
Darf ich da nicht sagen, der Sitz ist unbequem, weil dann irgendjemand sagt, jetzt bau doch
erst mal selbst einen besseren Sitz, bevor du das Ganze kritisierst.
Das sind immer so Argumente, die sind so, so, so, so low IQ three hat.
Da fällt mir gar nichts mehr dazu ein.
Und das siehst du an allen Ecken und Enden.
Lass mich doch daran erinnern.
Das erste Mal, wo mir so richtig aufgefallen ist, was die Leute für dummes Zeug schreiben,
also sinnloses Zeug.
Damals, als ich noch MMO gecriset, schon ewig her.
Ist mir damals schon aufgefallen, als ich MMO gecrindet habe, noch 24 7.
Da ging es immer darum, dass die Webseite des MMO Anbieters so schlecht zu benutzen
ist.
Da hat mal eine einen riesen Shitpost gemacht im offiziellen Forum, wie das denn sein kann,
dass die Webseite so schlecht ist.
Und ich muss ihm recht geben.
Die Webseite ist schlecht.
Und da gab es wirklich Leute, die gesagt haben.
So bringt das nichts.
Mach selbst erst mal eine bessere Webseite und dann schick es dem Hersteller, dass die
sie nehmen können oder so.
Alter Leute, seid ihr so dumm oder seid ihr so weltfremd?
Oder seid ihr einfach nur bescheuert?
Oder was ist los?
Oh Mann, das ist immer das beste Argument.
Alter, mach es doch selber erst mal besser.
Das heißt nicht, dass man einfach jetzt 30 Minuten so vom Leder zieht und abgrundtief
alles flamed.
Davon hat keiner was.
Aber wenn du es als User, sagen wir mal halbwegs, auch wenn da die Emotionen teilweise mit einem
durchgehen, wenn man sich schon irgendwie auf ein Game gefreut hat, wenn man als User
es halbwegs fundiert, was kritisiert, man muss kein Spiel programmieren können.
Man ist User.
Man spielt das Spiel.
Es gibt Aspekte, die einem nicht gefallen.
So, und wenn man diese Aspekte, die einem nicht gefallen, benennt, eventuell sogar noch,
wenn man das kann, mit Verbesserungsvorschlägen oder aber einfach nur sagt, das hat mir im
alten Teil besser gefallen, sondern zum Vergleich, das reicht, derjenige, der das Spiel spielt,
muss nicht in der Lage sein, ein besseres Game zu programmieren.
Warum?
Er ist Konsument in dem Fall.
Er ist User.
Er ist kein Anbieter.
Und Anbieter tun gut daran, darauf zu hören.
Natürlich kann man als Anbieter nicht immer auf alles hören, was die Leute sagen, weil
gerade, wenn man sich offizielle Foren anguckt, das Geheule ist teilweise unbegründet unglaublich
groß.
Man muss das filtern.
Deswegen finde ich es auch unglaublich wichtig, dass Hersteller eben auf Leute hören, die
Ahnung von dem Spiel haben.
Also, wenn ich ein Spiel machen würde, beziehungsweise wenn ich ein Spiel gemacht hätte, was eine
gewisse Bekanntheit erlangt hat, dann.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Das erste, was ich machen würde, ist, ich würde permanent, ich würde mir ein paar gute
Leute raussuchen, die das Spiel richtig gut spielen.
Am besten irgendwelche Semi-Pros oder Retired-Pros.
Wobei, Retired-Pros in einem neuen Spiel ist vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig, ja.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Also, ich würde mir wirklich S-Tier-Spieler raussuchen und dann würde ich die bezahlen,
dafür, dass die mit mir spielen.
Dass die mit mir konstant Balance-Sachen besprechen und mich beraten.
So, wie das übrigens Blizzard früher gemacht hat.
Die haben sich damals bei der Entwicklung zu World of Warcraft, haben die sich Top-Rate-Leute
geholt aus anderen Spielen, zum Beispiel aus EverQuest.
Jeff, Overwatch-Jeff.
Hier, er hier, Papa Jeff von Overwatch.
Der war früher Top-Raider in EverQuest.
Und den haben die sich geholt, damals, für die Entwicklung von World of Warcraft, unter
anderem, weil er ein High-End-Tier-EverQuest-Raider war und er wusste, worauf es ankommt.
Also, ähnlich würde ich das auch machen.
Hätte ich wirklich ein Spiel, was einen gewissen Bekanntheitsgrad hätte und ich möchte, dass
es Balance ist, ich würde permanent, ich würde nicht diese Blizzard-Taktik machen,
so nach dem Motto, wir sitzen im stillen Kämmerlein, umgeben uns mit Leuten, die uns permanent
Zucker in den Arsch blasen und dann denken, ja, keine Ahnung, alles ist fein.
Oder so wie DICE das bei Battlefield 2042 gemacht hat.
Ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt, also auf diesen Anspiel-Events, das war so ein krasses Rumgeschleime
die ganze Zeit.
Unglaublich.
Nicht alle, aber das, gerade im englischsprachigen Bereich, also das, was man gelesen hat, so
nach dem Motto, ihr habt da wirklich was am Laufen, ihr habt da was richtig, also, wo
ich mir gedacht hab, alter, das erste, was mir aufgefallen ist, als ich das Spiel gespielt
hab, ist, dass das flog, das erste, was ich, ich weiß noch, das erste, was ich gesehen
hab, als ich in diesem Anspiel, in dem Anspiel-Event, das erste Mal, als ich in einem Anspiel-Event
in das Game gegangen bin, das erste, was ich gesehen hab, ich bin gespawnt, hab in die
Luft geguckt und hab einen Jet gesehen, der so geflogen ist, Leute.
So.
Das hier, das hier ist der Jet.
Der Jet ist so geflogen.
Hab ich mir gedacht, das kann doch nicht gewollt sein.
Das ist das erste, was ich gesehen hab, als ich jemals in Battlefield 2042 reingespawnt
bin, der sich total beschissen unrealistisch bewegt hat.
Hab ich mir gedacht, was ist da los?
Aber die Leute voll am Ausflippen im Discord.
Oh, ist das toll.
You got onto something oder was auch immer.
Na gut.
Was auch immer.
Zumindest so würde ich das machen.
Ich würde mir Leute besorgen, ne muss ich nicht aktive Pros sagen, die wirklich gut
in dem Spiel sind und mit denen würde ich permanent Balance-Sachen besprechen und ich
würde mein Spiel, wenn es ein Multiplayer-Spiel ist, ich würde mein Spiel von Grund auf so
bauen, dass ich, wie sagt man so schön heutzutage?
Continuous Deployment.
Also dass ich kontinuierlich neue Updates pushen kann.
Natürlich kannst du nicht alle Updates pushen, ja gerade wenn du Client-Updates brauchst,
geht das nicht.
Aber ich würde es so aufbauen, dass du Server-Updates immer pushen kannst.
Das geht ja mittlerweile in Battlefield 2042 halbwegs, soweit ich das mitbekommen hab.
Und vor allem, dass ich Balance-Änderungen immer machen kann.
Also Änderungen, die nichts erfordern, außer das Ändern von irgendwelchen Zahlen.
Oder von irgendwelchen, ja Zahlen im Endeffekt, von Timern, von Damage-Werten, von irgendwelchen
solchen Sachen.
Das muss on the fly passieren.
Können, ja.
Also du musst sagen können, ah Mist, ich hab Mist gebaut, was weiß ich, das Schild von
Held A hat ja irgendwie viel zu viele Punkte in Kombination mit der Sache aus von B, ja
dann patchen wir das mal kurz irgendwie so.
Und dann hast du nämlich den großen Vorteil, wenn du das machen kannst.
Wenn du die Sachen patchen kannst, ohne drei Monate zu brauchen, dann hast du den Vorteil,
dass du auch mal, ähm, vielleicht eine Anpassung machen kannst, die ein bisschen zu viel ist,
aber dann kannst du relativ schnell iterieren und das Ganze auf ein sinnvolles, gut spielbares
Level packen.
Ja, ansonsten hast du das übliche, ich hab's ja schon oft gezeigt, ansonsten hast du das
übliche, ähm, Blizzard, Blizzard-Balancing und Blizzard-Balancing-Version.
Und Blizzard-Balancing, wissen wir ja alle, sieht im Endeffekt, sieht im Endeffekt so aus.
So, irgendwie Held X kommt raus, ja, das ist hier, das ist OP und das hier ist Suck.
So, und was weiß ich, Game kommt raus und Blizzard-Balancing mit Held ist halt das hier.
So, Held ist OP, Held ist OP, Held ist OP, drei Monate später kommt ein Patch, Held
ist absolut useless, absolut useless, absolut useless.
So, dann werden alle anderen Helden gepatcht oder was auch immer.
So.
Und dann wird das hier reworked, reworked von Helden, dann ist der noch OPer als am Anfang.
So, und dann wird er, dann wird er vielleicht genervt und ist dann komplett wieder useless.
Also, das hier, das hier ist Blizzard-Balancing.
So, so funktioniert das.
Und da würde ich alles dran setzen, dass das in dem Spiel, wo ich entwickelt, was ich
nicht mache, weil ich keine Ahnung von Spielen entwickle, dran setzen würde, dass man das
etwas weicher handhaben kann.
Ja, das muss on the fly gehen.
Und das in Kombination mit Leuten, die Ahnung vom Spiel haben, ich bin der Meinung, wenn
du, wenn du wirklich ein Competitive spielst.
Wenn du wirklich ein Competitive Spiel basteln musst, basteln, nicht basteln musst, basteln
willst, dann muss das vor allem, das muss natürlich Competitive auf allen Leveln sein,
aber es muss vor allem sich dadurch auszeichnen, dass es Competitive oder Balanced ist auf
dem absoluten Top-Level, also Balanced auf S-Tier-Niveau muss das Ganze sein.
Der Rest kommt von allein.
Weil anders, anders kannst du ja schlecht was balancen.
Also, wie möchtest du was balancen?
Du kannst Balancen für die, sagen wir mal so, 90% der Playerbase, die nicht gut ist
und dann kannst, hast du nichts, was ordentlich funktioniert, High-Level und alle spielen
das Gleiche.
Ich bin der Meinung, wenn du für S-Tier balancest, kommt das andere nach und nach.
So, und hauptsache on the fly.
Gut, was auch immer.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Ja, ihr sagt doch, das ist Blizzard-Balanced.
Das ist bei allem so.
Das ist bei allem, was die machen so.
DLCs-Heroes sind am Anfang OP, weil die Leute DLCs verkaufen wollen.
Ja, genau, sowas ist das.
Bei Destiny machen sie es mittlerweile auch so.
Ja, so musst du es ja eigentlich auch machen, weil die Entwickler, die sind, also wenn
die ihr eigenes Spiel spielen, da habe ich so meine Zweifel, ob die das machen, aber
wenn die Entwickler selbst ihr Spiel spielen, die sind schon ganz brauchbar mit der Zeit
in ihrem Game, wenn man das die Entwicklung überspielt, aber die sind halt nicht so gut,
wie beispielsweise, wie ich es gerade gesagt habe.
Wie beispielsweise wirkliche Semi-Pros in irgendwelchen FPS-Games oder halt irgendwelche Leute,
die explizit sich da Spaß dran haben, quasi irgendwelche unbalanced Kombinationen zu finden.
Und deswegen, warum sollte man diese Leute bekämpfen, sondern man sollte sie besser
auf die eigene Seite holen und sagen, okay, man sollte die übrigens auch bezahlen, ja.
Ich habe in ganz vielen MMOs gesehen, dass es irgendwelche, wie nennt man das?
Volontär? Ehrenamtlich, ehrenamtlich.
Dass es irgendwelche ehrenamtliche Programme gibt, so nach dem Motto, ja, es gibt jetzt
hier den ehrenamtlichen, sagen wir mal, was weiß ich, irgendwie Krieger-Community, also
nicht Commander, Krieger oder sagen wir mal so, Assassin-Community-Lead oder nee, nicht
Community, wie heißt das, irgendwie den, was weiß ich, Community-Ansprechpartner für
Klasse XY ehrenamtlich. Habe ich in ganz vielen MMOs gesehen, sowas in der Richtung.
Und dann hast du Leute, die stecken da wirklich so viel Zeit rein und so viel Energie und Geld
und Zeit in dieses MMO und schreiben für den Hersteller wirklich Berichte umsonst.
So nach dem Motto, so Eindruck von der Klasse, wie es aktuell da ist, wie das Balancing ausschaut
versus andere Klassenlisten-Skills, auf was du machen sollst. Und der Hersteller scheißt komplett drauf.
Ja.
Wo ich immer wieder erstaunt bin, dass das Leute tatsächlich ehrenamtlich immer noch machen
und sich dann auch noch abspeisen lassen mit Einzeilern im Endeffekt.
Also ich würde die Leute tatsächlich bezahlen dafür. Gerade wenn du irgendwelche Semi-Pos hast,
die sind natürlich darauf angewiesen auch, dass sie davon leben können.
Und, ja, egal. So, weiter, Video, fertig.
Dead by Daylight-Balance nicht für Top Tier und zieht dadurch viele Probleme.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Dead by Daylight irgendwie competitive ist.
Ähm, ja, StarCraft I hatte aber auch...
Ich glaube, bei StarCraft I sind ein paar Sachen zusammengekommen.
Erstens, dass die Leute damals bei Blizzard ihr Game selber rauf und runter gespielt haben.
Das war bei StarCraft II teilweise noch so.
Der StarCraft II-Multiplayer-Balance-Typ ist ja wohl eines der besten Random-Spieler,
war wohl einer der besten Random-Spieler der Welt.
Also der war wohl richtig gut, auch in der Korea-Ladder und so was. Also das war kein Kack-Noob.
Aber ich glaube, in StarCraft I kamen mehrere Sachen zusammen.
Erstens, dass die wirklich Leute hatten, die den Kram selber stundenweise am Tag gegrindet haben
und ein paar glückliche Fügungen zusammen.
Und, dass damals diese ganze koreanische Geschichte losgegangen ist
und die Koreaner haben diesen Kram irgendwie selbst gebalanced.
Das kann man schwer beschreiben.
Ich hab mir mal einen Videotreiber angeguckt, die Entwicklung von StarCraft, also von eSportplay StarCraft I.
Und da hast du richtig gesehen, es gab Dinger, die galten als gnadenlos OP.
Und da kam dann irgendwie ein super krasser Fifat-Koreaner
und hat gesagt, nee, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Wenn man das anders spielt, ist das andere viel besser.
Also, wenn man das ordentlich spielt, aus koreanischer Sicht, heißt 350 EPM 100 Sachen gleichzeitig machen.
Aber wenn man das richtig macht, dann ist das andere eigentlich mehr OP.
Und dann haben die Koreaner gesagt, okay, das ist dann doch gar nicht so schlecht die Klasse
oder in Kombination oder Units, die sonst keiner verwendet hat, waren auf einmal gut.
Und dann kam der nächste Sixhead-Koreaner und hat gesagt, haha, aber wenn man das noch anders macht
und dann irgendwie mit 5000 EPM spielt und quasi mit den Füßen auch gleichzeitig tippt,
dann ist das andere wieder besser.
Also irgendwie haben die Koreaner StarCraft I untereinander gebalanced mit noch immer mehr Fifat-Plays.
Ja, da musste Blizzard an StarCraft I gar nicht so viel machen.
Was auch immer. Also da kamen ein paar glückliche Sachen zusammen.
Aber da hat man auch gesehen, StarCraft I war halt auch für Top Tier balanced.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns aber endlich das Video an.
Was für ein Programm benutzt du, um deine Fotos zu bearbeiten?
Ich benutze hier Affinity Designer und Foto für meine Thumbnails.
Das ist ein sehr guter Stuttering.
Ach ja, Micro-Stuttering. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das Spiel Micro-Stuttering ist.
Ich dachte, es hat generell Stuttering.
Ganz im Ernst, ich habe das gespielt, ja.
Okay, also für das, dass es wohl ein ziemlich kleines Entwicklerstudio ist, ist alles okay.
Aber ich sehe das Spiel nicht, wo es rauskommt.
Vor allem, ich werde es nie wieder installieren, solange es mail.ru als Anti-Cheat verwendet.
Oh, vier Maps! Unglaublich! Ein halbes Jahr nach Release werden vier neue Maps erwähnt in den Spiele-Files.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen? Erwähnt! Nicht etwa reingepatcht.
Nein, nein, die werden erwähnt irgendwo in den Spiele-Files.
Also sprich, wir haben jetzt ein halbes Jahr ohne jeglichen Content, obwohl das Spiel eigentlich ein Service-Game sein soll.
Das kann man sich ausmalen. Das kann man sich nicht ausmalen, oder?
Ein halbes Jahr ohne Content in einem Service-Game.
Wo ist, was für ein, von was für einem Service reden die da eigentlich?
Wann ist eigentlich BF2020 Season 1 Start?
Wann ist denn das?
Okay, also. Anfang Juni Start, das ist ja nicht mehr so viel.
Mail.ru Anti-Cheat, jaja. Die haben Mail. Also nicht Battlefield, äh, World War 3 hat Mail.ru Anti-Cheat.
Okay. Kann ich... äh, Steam.
Steam.
Alter, jetzt krieg ich das alles auf Russisch, weil ich Mail.ru gesucht hab, oder was?
Welt im Krieg 3.
Ist alles klar.
Es ist Mail.ru Anti-Cheat, oder?
Das will ich nicht haben.
Ist das gut oder schlecht, dass ich schlecht, ich will kein Mail.ru Anti-Cheat haben.
...mean, that they will be made playable.
Rumors online suggest the reveal of this year's Modern Warfare sequel is fast approaching.
Okay.
Leaker Tom Henderson, the Modern Warfare...
Warum? Das ist eine gute Frage. Also, erstens möchte ich generell ungern Anti-Cheat haben, der sich quasi als Rootkits im System einlistet.
Das ist leider das Problem, ähm, bei vielen Anti-Cheats.
Die Sache ist nur die, ich traue den normalen Anti-Cheats schon nicht.
Und ich traue einem China-Chinesen Tencent Anti-Cheat oder einem Mail.ru Anti-Cheat noch weniger.
Und irgendwann ist diese Linie überschritten, wo ich sage, ich installiere es mir nicht.
Ich bin schon kein Fan von, ähm, normalen Rootkit-Style Anti-Cheat draufzuhauen.
Aber bei mir ist bei China-Chinesen und EU-Anti-Cheat, oder falls es nordkoreanischen Anti-Cheat gibt, keine Ahnung, dann insofern überschritten, dass ich mir es gar nicht installiere.
Ob die jetzt wirklich damit mehr krumme Dinge anstellen, wie beispielsweise der Web...
Wobei der Valorant Anti-Cheat ist ja auch so ein Ding, ja.
Äh, ob die mehr krumme Dinge anstellen, als beispielsweise, keine Ahnung, Apex mit ihrem Rootkit-Style Anti-Cheat, weiß man natürlich nicht.
Aber ich traue denen da mehr zu.
Im negativen Sinn.
Das heißt Mail.ru Anti-Cheat habe ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
To reveal will take place on Wednesday, June 8th.
This date lands just days before the Xbox Showcase on June 12th, where...
Ich muss das ja immer wieder sagen.
Dieser, das hat mich schon das erste Mal, äh, als ich das gesehen habe, getriggert, wo ich immer nicht verstehe, warum, ich habe es 500 Mal in diesem Trailer schon gesagt, ähm, warum läuft die auf das, auf die Motorhaube, um in das Auto reinzuschießen?
Das ist doch einfach nur, dass es cooler aussieht, oder?
Möchte die von dem Auto umgefahren werden?
Oder möchte die, äh, kann die von vorne nicht durchschießen?
Oder, warum will die sich, äh, will die ein besonders gutes Ziel abgeben, wenn sie aufs Auto klettert?
Ich versteh's nicht.
Das habe ich beim, beim Reveal-Trailer damals schon gedacht.
Warum klettert die aufs Auto, um da reinzuschießen?
...for the Xbox Showcase on June 12th, where more gameplay could be shown.
As usual, fans could expect a reveal of the game's setting and storyline.
Multiplayer content tends to be revealed later on.
Ja, das ist schwierig zu sagen, Chat.
Ähm, weil...
Ähm, das kann man schwer sagen.
Ich meine nur, weil es viele Attacken gibt, die irgendwie aus Richtung China oder aus Richtung Russland ausgehen,
also Absender-IP-technisch, muss es nicht zwangsläufig, also ich traue das denen auf jeden Fall zu,
sowohl den Chinesen als auch den Russen, ähm, muss es aber ja nicht zwangsläufig, ähm, bedeuten,
dass die eigentlichen Angreifer auch dort zugehörig sind, ja?
Ich habe letztens beispielsweise gelesen, in irgendeinem Artikel,
dass wohl VPNs, ich glaube nach, im Iran oder so, recht beliebt sind für irgendwelche Hacker-Sachen neuerdings.
Ich glaube auf, äh, ich glaube auf, ich, ich glaube bei Hacker-News irgendwo habe ich das gelesen,
dass jetzt gerade, ähm, ähm, iranische VPNs bei Hackern voll angesagt sind.
Ich wusste bis dahin gar nicht, dass es im Iran VPN-Anbieter gibt, aber anscheinend ist das so.
...here.
Apex Legends Mobile launched this week and was met with a very positive reception from fans.
However, some players...
Ich frage mich immer noch, wie man Apex auf Mobile mit, äh, also das ist ja ein relativ schnelles Game,
wie man das auf Mobile gescheit spielt.
Ich krieg ja, ich hab ja schon Anfälle bekommen bei normalen Mobile Games mit der Touchscreen-Steuerung und dann Apex.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du eh wieder cheaten mit nem Emulator und, und Maus und Tastatur oder Controller.
...are a little upset over one particular legend.
Fade is Apex Legends newest character but is exclusive to the mobile version.
According to Respawn Entertainment,
they currently have no plans to bring Fade to the PC or Console.
Naja gut, also, komm.
Man, man, äh, man muss es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben.
Es gibt bei uns sicherlich Sachen, gerade wenn man sich so Dinge anguckt wie von, von Chat-Kontrolle bis wir müssen immer mehr einschränken,
äh, die meiner Meinung nach auch in die falsche Richtung gehen.
Aber von, ähm, du wirst in ein Arbeitslager gesteckt oder verschwindest von der Bildfläche, wenn du was Falsches sagst,
oder wirst vergiftet oder sonst was, oder wirst gar erschossen,
sind wir ja noch ein bisschen weiter entfernt, ja, was ja auch ganz gut ist.
...version of the game.
They say he was designed specifically for the mobile game and would need a complete rework for other platforms.
CD Projekt Red announced that the Witcher 3's next-gen upgrade is now undelayed.
They stated that the long-awaited expansion is planned to release later this year.
This upgrade was announced way back in September 2020.
Also sprich undelayed bedeutet, man hat das Delay wieder rückgängig gemacht, also,
es erscheint wie geplant.
...but was delayed indefinitely in April.
Fans are delighted to see that things are back on track.
The next-gen upgrade is set to release on PlayStation 5 and the Xbox Series X and S consoles.
No other specific details have been shared yet, but the game's global community manager did share that there will be a time for that.
They have said, however...
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich auch nicht so genau verstehe?
Ist nicht Witcher 3 seit Release schon next-gen auf dem PC?
Also, warum brauch ich eine next-gen-Fassung?
Von dem, was ich auf dem PC seit acht Jahren oder zehn Jahren oder wann kam das raus?
Das ist eine Weile her.
...spielen kann.
Also, okay, sieben Jahre.
Also, ich mein, vielleicht, vielleicht, ich hab mich mit dem Remaster nicht großartig beschäftigt,
aber was cool wäre auf jeden Fall, wenn die die ganzen NPC-Models ein bisschen vielfältiger machen.
Dafür hab ich auch noch...
Also, es gibt Mods, die tauschen Charaktere aus, aber ich hab noch keinen Mod gesehen, wenn ihr da einen kennt, würde mich echt interessieren, der die NPCs vielfältiger macht.
Also, es gibt Mods, die die NPC-Models verbessern, aber es ist trotzdem so, dass wenn du in Witcher 3, sagen wir mal, zehn Quests machst, davon haben die Hälfte der Quests die gleichen NPCs mit unterschiedlichem Herkunft.
Also, die Haare der NPCs sehen dann ein bisschen anders aus, aber das Gesicht und das Model ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Also, wenn es da einen Mod gäbe, der vielleicht aus 30 verschiedenen NPC-Models, die es gibt, 60 verschiedene NPC-Models machen würde, das wäre nice.
Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass das Mod technisch gar nicht geht.
Da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher.
Weil ja in dem Game selbst wahrscheinlich hardcoded ist, welcher NPC welche Mod ist.
Und wenn das hardcoded ist, dass es halt eben, ja, dass die einfach nur 30, 40 verschiedene Models da verteilt haben, kannst du nicht einfach 60 Models machen für random NPCs, ohne die komplette Gamewelt durchzugehen und das zu, ähm, oder man randomize das irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Also, das, das, das, das würde für mich Witcher 3 nochmal so auf next level, ähm, bringen.
Wenn man die NPCs etwas, äh, besser verteilt, dass es nicht immer die gleichen sind.
Ich auch nicht, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich, ich hab mich da, ich hab mir das auch noch nicht angeguckt.
Okay, Witcher 3 next gen update.
Zeig mal.
Dif, Difference, Difference.
Okay, also, zeig her, Difference.
Äh, irgendwas mit Raytracing.
Okay.
Also, in jedem Fall, äh, Raytracing juckt mich so überhaupt nicht.
Loading times ist gut.
Ja, wie, das war's?
Reddit, Reddit.
Wir fragen Reddit, Reddit, Reddit weiß bei sowas immer Bescheid.
Reddit ist, äh, high IQ.
Äh.
Was ist denn der Unterschied?
Nichts, oder?
Man weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht weiß die Games da was dazu.
Was bringt das denn?
Sichtvolle Konsolenbesitzer ersparen.
Ähm.
Ja, das ist alles.
Ich kauf, ich kauf mir doch nicht wirklich.
Ich, ich kauf mir doch nicht das Spiel nochmal neu, weil ich da irgendwie Raytracen kann drinnen.
Ist das hier nicht sogar schon raus?
Man bekommt irgendeinen Witcher, Witcher äh, äh, Skin oder irgendwas.
Es gibt keine neue Storymission, glaube.
Haben sie doch irgendwo mal gesagt.
Man muss es nicht neu kaufen.
Sicher?
Das wär cool.
Price.
Ah.
Das ist gut.
Das find ich nice.
Aber dann, bedeutet das im Umkehrschluss auch.
Dass sich wirklich an Inhalten nicht viel ändern wird.
Also wenn du das, wenn die ein Free Update geben wird, dann wird sich da inhaltlich nicht so viel tun.
So.
Haben wir das Video heute irgendwann nochmal geschafft.
Next Gen Upgrade will include free DLC by Netflix's Witcher Show.
Alter, die, die Witcher-Serie, man.
Ich meine, das hat so, egal.
Da hab ich mich schon oft genug drüber ausgelassen.
Bohemia Interactive announced two games this week.
Arma Reforger and Arma 4.
Arma 4 is still a long way to go.
Das Spiel hat doch zeitgemäße Grafik.
Also ich finde ganz ehrlich, Witcher 3, okay, ja.
Du kannst natürlich immer noch ein paar Sachen drehen.
Ähm, gerade mit den Sachen, die du in den letzten Jahren an Techniken dazu bekommen hast, ja.
Aber vieles ist ja ohne das irgendwie grundsätzlich neue Assets reinzubringen und da Sachen umzuprogrammieren gar nicht möglich.
Also du kannst ja nur so viel machen, wie du machen kannst, ohne dass du viel Hand anlegen musst an das Game.
Deswegen glaube ich auch nicht, dass da viel kommt.
Also das ist irgendwie, die werden ein bisschen höhere auflösende Texturen machen.
Ja, äh, die werden vielleicht ein bisschen, äh, bessere Models machen.
Aber so Sachen wie das, was ich mir beispielsweise wünschen würde, dass nicht jeder, äh, dritte, vierte NPC gleich aussieht.
Das, das wär mal cool, ja.
Das, das, das wär wirklich, das wär wirklich pock.
By the way, Witcher 3 auf der Switch.
Das ist das hässlichste Game ever, Alter.
Sieht so, sieht so mies aus.
Was hältst du von Microsoft-Zertifizierungen oder auch anderen Zertifikaten wie CCNA?
Ja, kann man machen.
Ähm, ich fand's immer ein bisschen Zeitverschwendung und Geldverschwendung, je nachdem, ob es der Arbeitgeber bezahlt oder nicht.
Es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Also gerade im Netzwerkumfeld sind diese Cisco-Dinger tatsächlich relativ angesehen.
Ich mein, CCNA nicht wirklich.
CCNA, sogar ich hab ein CCNA.
Der ist aber mittlerweile abgelaufen.
Und ich hab wirklich keinen großartigen Plan von Cisco-Netzwerkgeräten.
Und, also, beim CCNA kommst du nicht sonderlich weit.
Das zeigt höchstens, du hast grundsätzliche Ahnung von Netzwerkgeschichten.
Äh, die höherwertige Zertifizierungen, ja, die sind sicherlich, denk ich, relativ gefragt, wenn du Netzwerksachen machst.
Gerade Cisco-Zertifizierungen.
Ich kann's dir aber nicht aus erster Hand sagen.
Ich weiß aber, dass die höheren Cisco-Zertifizierungen nicht ohne sind.
Ein Kollege von mir damals hat den, äh, Cisco Internet Engine, äh,
den, äh, Cisco Internet Engineer, oder wie heißt dieses Ding?
Ist das Cisco Internet Engineer?
Oder wie heißt, wie heißt das, das höchste Ding, was die haben?
Äh, hat jemand eine Ahnung davon?
Internet Expert ist es?
Was ist, was ist CCIE?
Internet Work Expert.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das das war.
Äh, ich bilde mir aber ein, dass der irgendwas gemacht hat in Richtung Internet Engineer.
Aber das ist, das ist das, glaub ich, ja.
Das ist aber auch schon...
Überlegen.
Das war noch, wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet hab.
Das war 2011 oder so, wahrscheinlich.
Und das war nicht ohne.
Aber der Typ war eh krass drauf.
Der hat da in seiner Freizeit für gelernt und hat dann, ähm, den, den...
Ist Cisco nicht ne private Firma?
Doch, klar, ist es.
Der hat da irgendwie privat für gelernt und hat dann, ähm, den, den, den, seinen Chef damals beschwätzt,
dass er die Zertifizierung machen darf.
Und...
Der hat die beim ersten, beim ersten Anlauf.
Easy.
Okay, zeig mal her, wie viele Zertifizier...
Oh, was zum...
Monk... Monka was, alter?
Gut.
Ach, das gibt es mittlerweile in verschiedenen Ausprägungen, oder was?
Du kannst CCNA in unterschiedlichen Sachen machen.
Also, als ich CCNA gemacht hab, das ist, wie gesagt, auch schon ne Weile her,
da kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern, dass es dort, dass es den CCNA in verschiedenen...
Ausprägungen gab.
Weil...
Also, wir haben Routing und Switching gemacht.
Wir haben ein bisschen Security gemacht, ein bisschen Wireless gemacht.
Gibt nur noch CCNA.
Vielleicht...
CCNN?
Warum sollte Cisco keine Zertifizierung anbieten?
Das ist, das ist ja, das ist ja quasi so ein, ein eigener Kosmos zum Geld machen, Zertifizierung.
Vielleicht ist das eben ja auch...
Vielleicht ist das auch nur so ein Querschnitt, der sagt, es gibt ein CCNA...
Nee, es gibt noch ein CCDA...
Was zum...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin mir...
Also...
Weil jemand im Chat gesagt hat, das ist in Deutschland, gibt es das nicht mehr.
Also, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass der, dass der irgendwas mit Internet-Engineering...
Da gibt es nur den.
Also, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass der Kollege damals das gemacht hat.
Aber wenn es das in Deutschland nicht gibt, vielleicht war es auch das.
Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es das hier war.
Ja.
Aber ansonsten, ich bin kein großartiger Zertifikate-Fan.
Weil ganz im Ernst, das meiste, was man in der IT macht, sind eh irgendwelche...
Ja, das, was es schwierig macht, sind unternehmensspezifische...
Äh...
Wirrungen.
Ja.
Und da bringt einem ein Zertifikat nichts.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt...
Zeig mal hier.
Mal angenommen, ich bin jetzt zertifizierter Exchange-Administrator.
Falls es sowas gibt. Wahrscheinlich.
Gibt es sowas.
Und ich nehme jetzt einen Job an, wo ich mich um E-Mails kümmern muss.
Allerdings, es ist Postfix.
Ist das schön und gut, dass ich weiß, wie ich mit E-Mails...
Was ich mit E-Mails machen muss.
Aber...
Wobei, das war noch nicht die halbe...
Es ist Postfix plus irgendwelche unternehmensspezifischen Datenbank-Gedingse im Hintergrund.
Dann bringt mir das nichts.
Und selbst, wenn ich mich mit Linux und Postfix auskenne, heißt das nicht zwangsläufig...
Dass ich mich mit diesem Setup auskenne.
Und die meisten, die ein bisschen Ahnung haben...
Wenn du jemanden hast, der sich mit Linux ganz gut auskennt...
Der kommt relativ schnell rein.
Wie der E-Mail-Geschichten aus Postfix und sonstigen Sachen administriert.
Kompliziert ist dann die unternehmensspezifische Implementierung.
Und was die sich da so vorstellen.
Und das bringt dir keine Zertifizierung der Welt.
Das lernst du erst dort vor Ort.
Und bringt dir meistens auch nur dort was.
Also das Wichtigste, den wichtigsten Skill, den man in der IT eh haben muss, ist...
Genug Wissen, dass man weiß, nach was man suchen muss.
Und genug Wissen, dass man mit Hilfe von Suchen und Nachlesen...
Relativ schnell in Themen, wo man keine Ahnung von hat, reinkommt.
Ansonsten...
Weiß nicht.
Da bringt einem Zertifizierung aber wenig.
Es bringt einem natürlich schon was.
Ich will jetzt nicht damit sagen, dass man sich in keinem Bereich auskennen soll.
Letztendlich dort, wofür man bezahlt...
Ist ja seine Expertise, beziehungsweise das Gebiet, je nachdem wie gefragt ist, wovon man Ahnung hat.
Also wenn die jetzt irgendwie wirklich einen...
Senior...
Keine Ahnung...
.NET Developer suchen...
Da bringt es nichts, wenn du sagst...
Ja, ich habe C-Sharp schon mal verwendet, aber ich kann mich schnell einarbeiten.
Das...
Ich glaube, das wird wahrscheinlich keinen überzeugen.
Aber, was du nicht können musst ist...
Irgendwelche unternehmensspezifischen...
Libraries und Helper-Sachen und Dinger, die die da...
Und Datenbank-Schemas und was auch immer, die die da programmiert haben.
Da musst du dich dann schnell einarbeiten können.
Und da bringt es dir gar nichts, dass du irgendeine Microsoft.NET Zertifizierung hast.
So, also was soll ich mir jetzt angucken?
Entry, Associate, Specialist, Professional, Expert.
Our Approach.
Okay, die haben das ein bisschen zusammengestaucht alles.
Es gibt bloß noch ein CCNA.
Aber es gibt mehrere Experts.
Und das Zeug ist auch teuer.
Du spielst Link to the Past Randomizer.
Spielst du manchmal irgendwo mit?
Ich gucke mir ganz gerne Streams an.
Ich finde das äußerst beruhigend.
So.
Ich rolle jetzt mal durch.
Kann das sein, dass wir das erste Level-Cap-Video immer noch nicht geschafft haben nach über einer Stunde?
Das ist ja heute wieder Wahnsinn, Alter.
Okay.
Jetzt aber endlich fertig.
Wir haben drei Minuten Video geguckt in 45 Minuten oder so.
Can't wait, Mann.
Wie schlecht.
Ich sollte doch ins Reaction-Business gehen, ne?
Oh yeah.
Ich finde übrigens Reforger ein unglaublich schlechter Name.
Erstens erinnert mich das sehr an Warcraft 3 Reforged.
Und Reforger klingt irgendwie holprig.
Was wird denn da neu gespielt?
Es wird eine Primär-Multiplayer-Mode genannt, die named Conflict.
Eine 51 km2-Map genannt, die Everon genannt und eine neue Mechanik genannt, die Workbench.
Das ist eine Kreativ-Suite für das Infusion-Engine, das das Spiel baut.
Es erlaubt Spieler, zu modieren und zu machen, was sie in der Welt mag.
Das selbe Engine wird für Arma 4 auch genutzt werden.
Also ich hab...
Ich hab das Spiel gestern oder so mal kurz beim Lost im Stream geguckt
und das sah nicht ansatzweise so gut aus wie hier.
... deutlich, dass sie hoffen,
Spielerinnen werden eine starke Verständnis vor dem neuen Game-Engine-Tool haben,
Tools by the time Arma 4 releases.
According to industry
insider Jeff Grubb, Star Wars Jedi
Survivor is the highly anticipated
sequel to Fallen Order. According
to Grubb, it will be revealed at Star Wars
Celebration in May and released
early next year. Grubb has also stated
that Cal Kestis from the first game
is still the main protagonist. However,
the Bespin Bulletin, a Star Wars News
outlet, shared conflicting information.
They believe the game will be split
between two different playable characters.
Fans speculate, we could play as
both Cal and a potential Padawan.
Both sources are confident details
will be revealed at Star Wars Celebration.
In other Star Wars News,
a patch has gone live for LEGO Star Wars
The Skywalker Saga.
The developers at TT Games noted
that the general improvements to the game's stability
and performance have been made. New capital
ships were added alongside additional
collectible items hidden around the
game world. Players are pleased with the patch,
though they feel more should be done to tackle
the issues with the Freeplay mode.
This mode has many annoying bugs,
including untracked progression and game
crashes. TT Games have yet
to comment on this mode directly,
but have assured players
that they are committed to improving the game further.
In a developer update,
Bungie teased the next dungeon
coming to Destiny 2.
It's
the biggest
patch.
The new patch is coming.
It's the new patch.
The new patch.
Oder? So wirkt das auf mich, wenn ich mir das, ja du kannst Destiny alle drei Monate eine Woche spielen, dann ist Ende. Ja, so wirkt das auf mich auch. Das einzige, was man glaube ich machen muss, ist sich Daily einloggen und bei diesem Daily Shop immer regelmäßig buyen, aber ansonsten.
Markus Phoenix ist für mich der blasseste Actionheld aller Zeiten, Alter.
Der Typ ist einfach nur so, wie er ist.
Der Typ ist einfach nur im Game, um im Game zu sein. Also, den hätten sie auch genauso gut durchsichtig machen können.
Also mit dünn meine ich nicht die Muskeln, ihr wisst was ich meine. Also, das ist der langweiligste Actionheld-Charakter ever. Also, keine Ahnung.
Man merkt, dass sie verletzt werden.
Dass sie irgendwas versucht haben, wollten, aber das hat nicht, keine Ahnung. Also, ich werde mit den Gears of War Characters nicht warm. Wobei ich sagen muss, das erste Gears of War fand ich richtig gut. Gerade im Koop. Das ist eines der nicesten Koop-Spiele überhaupt. Danach weniger, aber das erste war richtig gut.
Gears of War Franchise explicitly. The developers at the Coalition have stated that they won't be releasing a new game for some time.
So, fans speculate, that maybe a remastered collection would be the perfect way of bridging the gap. So, fans speculate, that maybe a remastered collection would be the perfect way of bridging the gap.
The future game show is set to return this summer.
Und außerdem ist Gears of War das einzige Spiel, die einen Charakternamen der Bert heißt.
It'll showcase over 40 games and PC-Console.
So, the event will kick off on June 11th, just a few days after Modern Warfare 2 is supposed to be revealed.
According to the event description, it'll showcase some of the world's biggest game franchises.
More rumors hint at the return of the beloved Silent Hill franchise.
What?
Last week, a series of potentially leaked screenshots surfaced online.
They apparently showcased a reboot of the series.
Industry insiders like Jeff Grubb all agreed that a remake of Silent 2 is also on the way.
It'll supposedly feature reworked puzzles, new endings and sidequests.
Apparently, it's in development at the...
Ist das nicht das Spiel, also woran er den Trailer von zeigt?
Ist das nicht das, was er machen wollte?
Und dann mit dem Hauptdarsteller doch jetzt, also nachdem er sich da mit Konami irgendwie verkracht hat oder so.
Ähm, woran, dass er dann den DHL-Simulator mit dem gleichen Hauptdarsteller rausgebracht hat?
Also Death Stranding.
Ich mein, okay, es gab einen Mini-Patch, der Mini-Sachen geändert hat.
Ja, das Spiel ist in einem besseren State als vorher.
Das heißt aber noch lang nicht, dass es in einem State ist, dass man das spielen will.
Was? Was?
Ja gut, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil keiner eine PS5 liefern kann und viele in Japan schon eine PS5 haben können.
Warum?
Ich habe übrigens immer noch keinen Plan,
warum man sich eine Xbox kaufen sollte aktuell.
Ich weiß auch
by the way nicht, warum man sich eine PS5 kaufen sollte
aktuell. Also ich habe keine und ich werde
mir auch keine kaufen. Ich habe mir die letzte Konsolengeneration
zu Release gekauft, wurde
einmal hardchebated mit der
Zwischenkonsolen-Release-Version,
obwohl ich schon zum Release der letzten Konsolengeneration
gesagt habe, die Dinger sind eigentlich
gemessen an dem, was drinsteckt
zum Release-Zeitpunkt viel zu schwach.
Das haben mir die Hersteller auch so gesehen,
haben dann auch mal ein Update verkauft, was ich mir nie gekauft
habe und ich habe die Konsolen
keine Ahnung, 10 Minuten, äh ne, 10 Stunden
jede vielleicht angehabt die letzten paar Jahre über.
Komplett useless.
Absolut useless.
Rausgeschmissenste Geld ever.
And I'll catch you next time.
Ja, catch you uns next time.
So, was ist das? Record
Chatsuit Mountain.
Warum genau wurde mir dieses Video
vorhin vorgeschlagen?
Okay, Sekunde, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Ist das TOS-Musik?
How fast
can a medic ascend
Helvelin
3100 Fuß?
Geht das vielleicht auch in
ordentlichen
944 Meter? Das ist ja gerade mal
der Feldberg bei uns
um die Ecke.
Frankfurt-Feldberg.
Der ist
Höhe, okay,
831, alles klar.
Ja, ungefähr.
Hm, das ist ja nicht so viel.
Okay,
ich frage mich, ob so ein Ding
bis zu wie viel Kilo so ein Ding geht.
Also, ich hab
neues Rekord-Low, Leute.
Gestern
99,35.
Aber ich glaube, mich könnte das Ding
noch nicht gut fliegen, oder?
Das sieht aus, als wiegt der die Hälfte von mir.
Oh, das ist schon nice, oder?
Das ist schon nice.
Das würde ich, also das ist was,
das stelle ich mir echt, das stelle ich mir cool vor.
Sag mal, mit was
wird denn das angetrieben?
Ich sehe da jetzt weder großartigen
äh, warme Luft,
die rauskannst du ja auch gar nicht, weil
da verbrennt da sich ja ein Pobbes.
Ähm, ja, das, das ist gut.
Das ist halt irgendeine Turbine.
Aber,
ähm, also, und hier irgendwelche, irgendwelche
Lüfter drin zum Steuern.
Hier oben, hier,
hier drumherum wird wahrscheinlich Treibstoff sein, oder?
Also, im Prinzip, das hier ist eine Turbine
und drumherum wird wahrscheinlich alles voller Treibstoff sein.
Ähm, mal ganz davon,
abgesehen, ich kann mir vorstellen,
sonderlich lange wird das auch nicht
funktionieren.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich eine Viertelstunde oder so mit
noch nicht mal wahrscheinlich kürzer.
Aber das ist doch mal was.
Du musst aufpassen, dass er nicht gegen einen Baum
fliegt. Also, so schnell, so schnell
ist der auch gar nicht.
Das ist aber richtig nice.
Kann man damit unbegrenzt hochfliegen?
Nee.
Kannst du nicht.
Man kann es davon abgesehen, der hat ja auch keine Atemgeschichten
an und sonst was. Allein schon da,
könnte er nicht, sonderlich hochfliegen.
Ich meine, geil ist das schon, oder?
Also,
das stelle ich mir äußerst pock vor.
Und jetzt?
Treibstoff leer.
Wir müssen mal gucken,
wie lang es insgesamt gedauert hat.
Wir gucken uns mal die Uhrzeit an, wenn er landet.
Wie laut ist das Ding?
Abfuck brutal laut
wahrscheinlich.
Ich meine, du hast eine Turbine auf dem Rücken.
Das muss laut sein.
3 Minuten 30, okay.
Das bezweifle ich.
Das bezweifle ich, dass du dabei einen Sprint einlegst.
Das bezweifle ich, dass du in 3 Minuten
900 Höhenmeter hoch sprintest.
900 Höhenmeter sind ja
zu Fuß.
Das machst du garantiert nicht.
Kann er wieder runterfliegen?
Weiß nicht, ob er wieder runterfliegt.
Da bist du mit dem Heli schneller.
Ja, das bestimmt.
Die Sache ist, vielleicht benutzt du das halt an...
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob du mit dem Heli fliegen könntest
bei so einem Wetter.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Also, wie schnell man rennen kann,
merke ich mir immer.
Der Marathon-Weltrekord ist,
also es sind irgendwie 42 Kilometer
in
durchschnittlich
kmh, glaube ich,
ist der gelaufen.
Moment.
Marathon
World Record
Pace
2 Stunden 42
2 Stunden, genau.
2 Stunden
für 42 Kilometer.
Ja gut, dann weißt du,
der muss ja ungefähr
kmh...
Ja, ungerecht ist das eine Geschwindigkeit
von 20,59
Kilometer die Stunde.
Also, der Weltrekord
liegt bei pro Kilometer
ungefähr
3 Minuten pro Kilometer.
So, natürlich, natürlich,
die laufen etwas länger
als nur den Berg hoch, aber du kannst davon
ausgehen, dass der Typ
auch so schneller
läuft, selbst wenn der danach den
Marathon weiterläuft, als wir
den normalen Kilometer.
Äh, also das
ist mega krass, ja.
Und das schaffst du im Leben nicht.
Ja, ich kenne das.
Es gibt sogar ein Video dazu.
Es gibt sogar ein Video zu, Moment.
Ähm,
20,
kmh...
Äh, was heißt denn Laufband?
Treadmill oder sowas, oder?
Auf Englisch, Treadmill, ja.
Da gibt es sogar ein Video zu, das ist witzig.
Da fallen die Leute aufs Maul.
Ähm, okay.
Hier, das da.
Guck mal, die sind mega
am Flitzen, Alter.
Und das rennt der Typ einfach mal
42 Kilometer lang.
Guckt euch das an.
Die schaffen das in ein paar Sekunden und der Typ
rennt jetzt einfach 42 Kilometer.
Okay, da siehst du halt, welche Leute das können.
Also, also ich würde, weil ich würde es, bei mir würde
das ungefähr so aussehen.
Bei mir würde das ungefähr so aussehen, wie bei dem.
Bei mir würde das nach fünf Sekunden so aussehen, ja.
Na, der, der hat's, der, der hat's drauf.
Aber krass, oder?
Also, die haben's, mega, also der Typ ist, geht ab.
Also generell, Marathonläufer, die gehen mal richtig ab.
So, was haben wir als nächstes Video?
I made my coffee machine wireless mit einem ESP2-Navigator.
I made my coffee machine wireless with an ESP2-Navigator.
Okay, lass mal überlegen, was könnte der Typ machen?
Der nimmt eine Kaffeemaschine, muss abends Pulver reinfüllen,
weil Pulver kriegt er mit einem ESP32 nicht da reingefüllt.
Pulver reinfüllen, im Prinzip braucht er nichts anderes
wie ein Relay, was die Stromzufuhr ein- und ausschaltet.
Und da braucht man kein ESP32 reinzumachen mit einem Relay,
sondern irgendeine x-beliebige WLAN-Steckdose würde es auch tun.
Schau mal mal.
Nothing is worse than waking up and your coffee isn't done.
This happened to me last week and I realized I had to make a change.
Now, you could go out and spend $100 on a coffee machine with a clock and a timer,
but I already had a coffee machine and I already had an ESP32.
Man kann doch einfach eine WLAN-Steckdose nehmen.
So, in this video, I'm gonna hack my coffee machine.
Now, putting the machine on a timer would be too easy.
I want this coffee machine to be controlled wirelessly using a web-server that I'll write in this video.
From...
Ja gut, aber Kaffee und Wasser kannst du abends schon reinmachen, theoretisch.
Verkalkt dann vielleicht ein bisschen.
Nein, ich hab mir den Wasserkocher nicht geholt, das war Blödsinn.
My phone, I can say turn me on or turn me off.
The first step is to take the machine apart and figure out how do the controls work.
How does the machine get turned on?
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, so eine Kaffeemaschine ist relativ simpel.
Ich glaube, so eine Kaffeemaschine ist relativ simpel.
Du hast einen Stromanschluss, beziehungsweise du hast einen Schalter, wahrscheinlich ist das hier der Schalter,
und du hast irgendwo einen Stromanschluss und das wird, das, also, da wird nicht viel sein.
Das wird einen Stromanschluss haben, das wird in den Schalter gehen und dann zur Heizung.
Also, viel mehr wird das wahrscheinlich nicht sein.
Ein Vollautomat-WiFi-fähig machen, ja, das wäre cooler.
Und da bin ich mir sicher, gibt es bestimmt schon Projekte.
Ja, okay, das sind ESP32s mit einem Relay dran.
E-Z.
Easy.
Das würden wir ja auch hinkriegen.
Easy as a fuck.
The ESP32 will digitally control the machine.
Here you can see there are three lines, one for neutral and the other two are hot.
The switch connects the two black cables and that third line is just to ground the LED.
So, effectively, we can throw out the neutral.
So, effectively, we can throw out the neutral cable and not worry about it.
Ja, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer das neutral Cable raus, rausschmeißen, das, das ist die best, die beste Idee aller Zeiten.
So, that those lines are 120 volts and my ESP is 5 volts.
So, what do we do?
The answer is we go on Amazon and we acquire some relays.
Relays are a device that can be used to control one voltage.
Das ist billig, billig, lasst mich raten, das werden, das werden jetzt diese blauen AliExpress-Schienakegner.
Das sind Chinesen-Relays sein, wartet ab.
Pass auf blaue Chinesen-Relays gleich.
Ja, es ist ein Relay.
Es gibt ja auch zig verschiedene Typen von Relays.
Massive unboxing, LSMA.
Blauen, sind es die blauen China-Chinesen-Relays?
Zeig her.
Das sieht, das sieht sehr danach aus.
Ja, ja, ich wusste es, Alter.
Es sind die blauen, es sind die blauen China-Chinesen-Relays.
Was?
Ha, ich wusste es.
Genau die Dinge, Alter.
Wobei ich ehrlich gar nicht weiß, ob das China-Chinesen-Relays sind.
Das sind die Standarddinger, die es auf jedem billigen Bausatz gibt.
Von denen habe ich auch einige hier rumfliegen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob China Relays sind, ehrlich gesagt.
Das hier ist ja das Relay, der Rest ist ja alles...
Guck mal, ja, ja, ja.
Da ist es hier.
Winnie Pool Language.
Das TÜV-Logo ist drauf, das ist bestimmt echt.
Das CE-Logo ist bestimmt auch drauf, das ist bestimmt alles komplett legit.
Was sagt die Versicherung, wenn das Ding die Bude abfackelt?
Dass das davon die Bude abfackelt, sehe ich jetzt nicht, wie das passieren sollte.
Aber wenn es passiert und man das rausbekommt, ist es natürlich blöd.
Aber ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie das das auslösen sollte.
Ich meine...
Zwei Kabel da rein und schalte die dann und dann geht es an und...
Dass das abfackelt, ist ja recht unwahrscheinlich.
Ich habe in der Vergangenheit Tutorials gemacht, wie man den ESP32 auf den Wifi-Netzwerk verbindet und auch einen TCP-Server hostet.
Wir werden das gleiche Konzept in diesem Video nutzen und den TCP-Server als Web-Server verwenden, den ich mit meinem Handy verbinden kann.
In dieser Zeit...
I3 und WIM.
Ich würde zwar im Leben nicht C++ in WIM programmieren, aber...
Wobei, es ist direkt ESP-Dings gedönst, dann ist es nur C.
Nicht freiwillig in WIM, aber immerhin...
Er hat schon mal den richtigen Window-Manager und den richtigen Editor.
Zeigt er hier sein Wifi-SSD und Passwort?
Weiß ich nicht, ich sehe es nicht.
Seht ihr es?
Ich sehe es nicht.
Das müsste ich auch mal so just for fun
irgendwie sowas in den Hintergrund machen.
Irgendein Dude, der tippt,
das muss ja nicht mal ich sein, und einen Editor
overlayen.
Das sieht einfach mehr Hackerman aus.
Ja, wenn das abfackelt, hast du gelitten.
Das ist der Grund,
ich könnte mir das ohne Auto
komplett gar nicht vorstellen.
Da, Benzel, danke für den Sub.
Boah, ich könnte ohne Scheiß, Leute,
ich könnte nicht ohne Auto komplett programmieren.
Ich hätte keine Ahnung,
ich hätte wirklich keinen Plan.
Ich könnte mir merken, dass das wahrscheinlich
GPIO set level heißt, aber ich könnte mir
nicht merken, dass das GPIO set level heißt.
Ich könnte mir nicht merken, ob es GPIO set level ist,
oder set GPIO level.
Weil manche Sachen fangen ja auch gerne mal mit set und get an.
Auto komplett, best, fertig.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich,
habe ich letztens gesehen in einem Video,
jetzt kommt absolut Pfeifert-Thematik,
ähm,
wusstet ihr eigentlich,
dass,
ähm,
also mit dieser Funktion kriegst du ja raus,
wie lang der Text ist.
Also besser gesagt, wie lang
bis zum ersten Null-Character.
Wusstet ihr,
dass es mittlerweile auf aktuellen
Intel-CPUs, und ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob das Intel-only ist, oder
äh, nicht,
dass es einen extra
Assembly-Befehl gibt, oder einen extra
Assembler-Befehl gibt,
wo du quasi,
anstelle, also, dass du quasi
äh, Strille, also
Länge rausfinden, dass du das quasi
mehr oder weniger direkt in einen
Assembler-Befehl übersetzen kannst.
Also sprich, es gibt eine,
eine interne Instruktion
für die CPU, die quasi mehr
oder weniger Strillen macht.
Habe ich letztens in einem Video gesehen.
Wusste ich auch,
dass die so advanced sind mittlerweile,
was da drin ist.
Ja. Wollte ich jetzt mal sagen, ja.
Wie heißt der Assembler-Befehl?
Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich letztens in einem Video gesagt.
Äh.
Muss ich mal gucken, vielleicht finde ich das Video.
Für unseren zweiten Test werden wir diesen Web-Server nutzen,
um zu sehen, ob wir den Relay kontrollieren können.
DC-Plus wird unser 5-Volt-Service sein,
DC-Negativ wird die Grundlage sein,
und das In-Signal wird Pin 23 sein,
wo das GPIO passiert.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt,
das ist jetzt klassische.
Und ich versuche, mit meinem USB-Kabel ein paar Mal zu kämpfen,
bis wir zum Ende kommen.
By the way, an der Stelle,
was ganz praktisch wäre,
ähm, wenn er ein bisschen
kleineres Board genommen hätte, weil der braucht
die ganzen GPIOs gar nicht.
Und gerade ESP8266,
die dafür auch Lock-Herst
ausgereicht hätten, gibt es schon
in relativ kleinen.
By navigating to the website and saying
turn me on, we're able to actually
power on the relay and you can hear that click
is the sound of that coil energizing
and flipping that switch on, although the
coffee machine at this point is unplugged.
Great success.
Moving on to the final test.
Does our machine work?
Lass mich raten,
es funktioniert. Ja!
Also ganz ehrlich, großartig
kompliziert ist das jetzt nicht
gewesen.
Moment!
Der hat das noch nicht mal eingebaut?
Ja, das ist ja
mies.
Der hätte jetzt noch einen Spannungswandler hingemusst
und dann
das Ganze in irgendeiner Art und Weise
kleinere Bauteile
und dass das da reinpasst.
Nach dem Video baut er das
wieder ab, ja garantiert.
Und deswegen, du kannst ohne Probleme
in der IoT WLAN Steckdose nehmen.
Mal gucken, ich habe das letztens in einem Video
gesehen. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Vielleicht habe ich das Video
sogar offen. Ich glaube, ich habe nämlich vorhin
Intel Assembly Instructions
are wild. Tatsächlich,
doch, das ist das.
Was ist das denn?
Lass mich auch unterstrichen.
Das ist das.
So?
Alles klar.
Also,
Also die Zeitangabe da unten erscheint mir ein wenig überzogen für die Zeit, was eine CPU braucht, um das auszuführen.
E-C-X ist deklariert und dann E-C-I bewegt sich auf den nächsten Charakter.
Am Ende der Instruktionen ist E-C-X mit der negativen Länge des Strings erzeugt.
Negate die E-C-X-Value und boom, das ist deine Stringslänge.
Abonnieren für mehr verrückte Intel-Instruktionen.
Ich sehe dich im nächsten Video.
E-C-X ist deklariert und dann E-C-I bewegt sich auf den nächsten Charakter.
E-C-X ist deklariert und dann E-C-X ist deklariert.
Das Einzige.
Die Teilnehmer haben zwar alle einen PC zu Hause.
Was ist denn das?
So ein DSL-Modem?
Oder was soll das sein?
Aber was das Neue, Schnelle...
Ja, das ist ein...
Leute, das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr.
Wisst ihr, was das ist, was die in den Händen hält?
Was es heute nicht mehr gibt?
Richtig, das ist ein NTBA.
Das ist für ISDN-Gedöns.
Du hast ja damals angeschlossen,
Splitter in den Splitter
DSL-Modem
in den Splitter-NTBA.
Ich glaube, später gab es
NTBA und Splitter sogar in einem Gerät.
Gut, aber ISDN braucht ja heute keiner mehr.
Beziehungsweise eigentlich
von den Funktionen her ist ISDN
eine recht coole Geschichte gewesen.
Aber komplett
außer Mode gekommen.
Was das neue, schnelle Internet
wirklich kann, ahnt kaum einer.
Boah!
In Zeiten, in denen WWW häufig
mit weltweites Warten übersetzt...
Was ist ein Splitter?
Ein Hub oder so ein Teil?
Leitung auf Telefon, ISDN...
Nee, ein Splitter ist dafür da,
dass das, also...
Jetzt kommt irgendwo dein Kupferkabel
in die Wand, da ist eine Telefonbuchse
und da steckst du in den Splitter sein.
Und der Splitter splittet die Band...
Also, nee, nicht die Bandbreite, die Frequenzen.
Ein Splitter splittet die Frequenzen
für DSL
und Telefon.
Das macht einen Splitter.
Im Deutschen nennt sich das wahrscheinlich
Frequenzweiche oder irgendwie sowas.
Kein Schlimmer, das habe ich mir jetzt
gerade ausgedacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das wirklich gibt.
Splitter.
Frequenzweiche. Gibt's das Wort?
Eine Frequenzweiche.
Okay.
Ähm, nee, ich glaube,
das war was anderes.
Zumindest für Telefonie und Internet.
In Zeiten, in denen WWW
häufig mit weltweites Warten
übersetzt wird...
...geändert.
...vorbei. Noch nie war das
World Wide Web so schnell wie heute.
Fernsehsendungen, Spiele, Musik und Videos,
die Inhalte im...
Leute, das war
HD
High Res Multimedia
damals, ja?
41 Kilowatt-Sekunde.
Huge!
Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben,
es gibt Leute, die haben damals Porn geguckt
in dieser Auflösung, ja?
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen heutzutage.
Genießen kann man sie vor allem
der Digital Subscriber Line,
kurz DSL, dem High-Speed-Internet-Anschluss
schlechthin.
Das Prinzip, die Leitung wird in einem
sogenannten Splitter aufgeteilt.
Oh, jetzt kriegen wir es nochmal erklärt.
Signal zum Telefonieren und...
Super-Dreieck, also das ist ja mal hier
High-IQ-Render schlechthin.
...für den Datenstrom zum PC.
Vorteil, der Benutzer ist während der Computersitzung
immer telefonisch erreichbar.
Vom Splitter gehen die Daten dann zu einem
Router und weiter zum Rechner.
Ein Vergleich zeigt die
Möglichkeiten, die DSL bietet.
Während ein ISDN-Anschluss links
für den Aufbau einer Seite mit einigen Fotos
rund 13 Sekunden benötigt hat.
Nee, nee, nee, das muss, das, Leute, Leute,
das liegt daran, das hier ist Windows und das hier ist Mac.
Oder ist das überhaupt Mac?
...DSL, dieselbe Seite in gerade mal 0,9 Sekunden.
Ja, natürlich liegt es nicht an DSL.
...Sekunden auf dem Bildschirm.
Noch deutlicher ist der Unterschied
bei sogenannten Videostreams.
Oben mit ISDN stoppt der Filmtrailer
bereits nach wenigen Momenten.
Über DSL läuft er flüssig
und ohne Unterbrechungen durch.
Doch nicht nur
Unterhaltung im Internet wird durch die
neuen Geschwindigkeiten noch attraktiver.
Vielen Benutzern, wie dem
Fußballmanager Michael Brez...
Riesenbildschirm, Alter! Riesenbildschirm,
14-Zoll-Bildschirm!
...Bundesligisten Hertha BSC hat der Highspeed-Zugang
mit neuen beruflichen Möglichkeiten eröffnet.
Gut, wir holen natürlich täglich aktuelle
Informationen über unsere Mannschaft, über unseren Verein
aus dem Internet und wir
beschäftigen uns natürlich in erster
Linie mit Spielern, mit eigenen Spielern,
aber vor allen Dingen natürlich auch mit Spielern...
Der hat damals geguckt, ob die Spieler
nicht irgendwelche blödsinnigen Sachen
irgendwo in irgendeinem Interview erzählt haben.
...verobachten, also das, was unter dem
Oberbegriff Scouting läuft.
Und da holen wir die wesentlichen Informationen
aus dem Internet.
Was muss das Internet sein für jemanden
wie Sie?
Es muss einfach zu bedienen sein und es muss
natürlich sehr, sehr schnell sein.
Und das alles ist mit dem DSL-Anschluss gegeben.
Okay, der Typ ist gesponsert von der Telekom.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wer damals mit
gesponsert hat, aber wahrscheinlich die
Telekom.
Daniel Lull, danke für den Zap.
Einige Nationalspieler hat auch die Scheu
vor technischem Zubehör verloren.
Ja, so eine Tastatur, so eine Tastatur kann
man schon mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Angst vor haben, ja.
...zu zeigen, das ist eigentlich relativ
einfach. Wir brauchen eigentlich nur so eine
Starterbox, dann natürlich das...
Arcor, stimmt, das gab es damals auch noch.
Ist das nicht heute, ist Arcor nicht heute
Vodafone?
Ja.
Und den Modemanschluss, also das sind
gerade mal drei Kabel, die man stecken muss.
Arcor war auch Sponsor, ja, das passt ja.
...verbunden, dann müssen wir halt nur noch...
Natürlich, das ist, das ist sowas von
gesponsert.
...die eigentliche Verbindung herstellen und
das sieht man, glaube ich, dann auch ganz gut,
dass das sehr, sehr schnell funktioniert,
wenn wir hier mal den Button klicken.
Wer hat denn das Ding verwendet zum
Einwählen, Alter? Internet Explorer 5, so
muss das sein.
...angelockt, also das ist schon eine
wesentliche Erleichterung.
Doch nicht immer ist das mit der Technik
so einfach und damit...
Er guckt irgendwie ein bisschen leidend
bei diesem Interview, oder? Guckt euch
das mal an.
...im Internet eingeloggt, also das ist
schon eine wesentliche Erleichterung.
Er guckt irgendwie nicht gerade, sondern
nicht glücklich.
Doch nicht immer ist das mit der Technik
so einfach und damit verdient der Mann
vor dieser Tür sein Geld.
Es ist heute auch nicht einfach.
...Schulze Baldauf von Calle PC, sie
hatten angerufen beim DSL-Anschluss.
Andreas Baldauf rückt dieser Tage häufig
zu schwierigen Fällen wie Monika Schulze
aus. Sie ist DSL-Neukundin
und hat am Morgen Post mit der Hardware
für den Internetanschluss bekommen.
Nach dem Auspacken die Ernüchterung.
Dann habe ich gesehen, dass sie nicht mal
weiß, welches Kabel wo reingehört und
wo das hin...
Die meisten Kabel von diesen Dingern
passen doch nur in eine Richtung, an eine
Stelle rein.
...gehört und auch wenn ich mir den PC
angucke, weiß ich auch nicht, wo es da
hinten reingesteckt wird.
Bedienungsanleitungen sind hier dabei, sehe ich.
Monika, Alter!
Ja, klar.
Und?
Aber ich dachte dann, ich es sowieso nicht
hinkriege, rufe ich immer lieber...
Ja gut, ja gut, kann ein bisschen Geld ausgeben.
Der Mann von Caller PC benötigt für die
Installation nur wenige Minuten und zeigt
seiner Kundin sogleich, wie einfach das
anschließen sein kann.
Die Kabel sind idiotensicher gestaltet
und passen nur in die...
Oh! Leute, das hätte Twitter heute, diese
Formulierung hätte Twitter heute schon
zur Weißglut gebracht.
Pass mal auf.
Der Mann von Caller PC benötigt für die
Installation nur wenige Minuten und zeigt
seiner Kundin sogleich, wie einfach das
anschließen sein kann.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Die Kabel sind idiotensicher gestaltet.
Da wäre Twitter hardcore gedriggert heute
schon drüber, über diese Formulierung.
... und passen nur in die für sie
vorgesehenen Buchsen. Nach dem
Verstöpseln folgt das Einrichten der
Gerätschaft.
1&1 Profi Dealer. Heutzutage würdest du dir unter dem
Namen irgendwas Illegales vorstellen, wo du
nur mit dem Tor-Browser drauf kommst.
Okay, es ist ja auch nicht der Dealer,
sondern der Deiler quasi.
... per CD-ROM. Das Programm fragt nach
PIN und Passwort, die im Briefumschlag
mitgeliefert werden. Kurz darauf ist
Monika Schulze online. Ein Routine-Eingriff,
den sich der Mann vom Service-Dienst
natürlich bezahlen lässt. Na klar, würde
ich auch machen. Da gibt's nichts kostenlos?
... bei uns ab 28 Euro pro Stunde los.
Das werden wir auch hier in dem Fall
ansetzen. Da müssen wir nicht den höheren
Tarif wählen. Das ist jetzt einfach die
normale Installation. Einmal DSL, dann
DSL und das geht dann weiter zur
Netzwerkinstallation, etc. Was ist das?
Es kann dann schon mal bis zu 54 Euro pro
Stunde gehen, aber das ist eher der
Ausnahmefall. Aber... Das ist aber billig!
Guck mal hier, die bezahlt am Ende 30 Euro
oder so. Surfen mit DSL-Antrieb hat seinen
Preis. Über 20 sogenannte Provider bieten
den Breitbandzugang ins Netz an. Wer sich
dafür entscheidet, sollte sich... Ah, die
gute... Ende der 90er... Ich meine, das ist
2002, aber das kann man mal so als Ende der
90er durchgehen lassen. Die Webseiten von
2002... Über 20 sogenannte Provider bieten den
Breitbandzugang ins Netz an. Das war noch
zu Zeiten vor HTML5, vor CSS3, vor
irgendeinem ordentlichen JavaScript-Standard.
Das war noch, wie sagen wir so, wilder Westen
quasi. Webentwicklung 2002. jQuery dürfte
damals der heiße Scheiß gewesen sein.
Ich weiß... Bin mir gar nicht sicher, wann
jQuery rausgekommen ist.
Oh, fuck! Das ist pre-jQuery! Ach du
Scheiße. Okay, da geht nix. Ne. 2014. Ne. 2005.
2005. Okay, Leute. Das ist pre-jQuery.
Da ist... Da ist komplett...
...durch. Also...
Wer sich dafür entscheidet, sollte sich
zunächst einen Überblick über die Kosten
verschaffen. Neben der obligatorischen
Tele... Gutes... Gutes 100-Mbit-Netzwerk.
Von Grundgebühr sind das die Monats...
Oh, ich bin gar nicht sicher, Ben.
Waren das schon 100-Mbit, Leute?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Mit RJ45-Stecker, also
das war schon 100.
...bereitstellungsgebühr für das DSL und der
jeweilige Monatstarif...
Fällt euch mal auf, dass das genau das
gleiche kostet wie heute. Aber heute ist in der Regel ein bisschen schneller.
...Einrichtungsgebühr als Erstkunde.
Die Lua-Spike. Moin. Danke für den Zapp.
Andreas Baldauf von CallAPC bei seinem nächsten Hausbesuch.
CallAPC? Wie darf man sich das bildlich vorstellen?
Der hat am... Computer unterm Arm, oder?
Der hat am... Computer unterm Arm, oder? Der hat am... Computer unterm Arm, oder?
Die Lauerentung sei tot, klagte sie am
Telefon. Der Grund für den Ausfall
ist diesmal aber nur ein Wackenkopf.
Ja, kein Wunder, wenn sowas unterm Tisch hängt mit dem Kabelsalat, dann kommst du ja
mit dem Fuß dran und reißt die Hälfte runter.
...Kontakt in den Datenkabeln, kein Einzelfall.
Zweitgrößter Provider Deutschlands ist die Firma 1&1. Die Schaltzentrale des Unternehmens
im Pfälzischen Montabaur ist eine Hightech-Festung hinter Brandschutzmauern und Sicherheitsglas.
So, wir sind jetzt hier in unserem 1&1 Rechenzentrum unter der Erde.
Wie Sie sehen, ist es nicht so einfach hier reinzukommen.
Und überall sind Kameras, wo man sie beobachtet jetzt die ganze Zeit.
Und was Sie hier sehen, diese blauen Türen.
Das ist der Vorgänger von Marcel Davis quasi.
22.000 Server.
Ich zeige Ihnen jetzt mal einen Raum.
Voll gestopft.
Marcel Davis 1.0.
Beta.
Modernster Elektronik.
Den hohen Preis für DSL-Anschlüsse erklärt Vorstandssprecher Andreas Gauger
mit diversen Zusatzleistungen, die der Kunde bekommt.
Ob er sie will oder nicht.
Bei 1&1 bieten wir einige sehr spannende Extraservices.
Dafür haben wir auch hier dieses tolle Rechenzentrum gebaut.
Wir machen Ihnen einen Virenschutz für Ihre E-Mail.
Sie bekommen Möglichkeiten, einen Anrufbeantworter im Internet zu haben.
Eine eigene Homepage.
Ein Anrufbeantworter im Internet.
Das betreiben wir hier aus diesem Rechenzentrum.
Der Anwender kann in Deutschland aus mehr als 140 verschiedenen DSL-Tarifen auswählen.
Ein wahrer Dschungel.
Eine Mischung aus Messenger, E-Mail-Programm, Browser.
Teilweise noch BTX gab es früher bei der Telekom noch.
Falls irgendjemand BTX kennt.
Das war noch pre-WWW.
Bildschirm-Text.
BTX.
Sah ein bisschen aus wie Videotext.
Da gibt es für jeden Benutzertyp das Passende.
Ein Einsteiger oder Normal-User benutzt DSL, um seine E-Mails regelmäßig zu checken,
und auch mal bei Ebay ein Schnäppchen zu ergattern.
Also ich habe zu dieser Zeit angefangen 2002 24-7 MMO-Kreiselgrind zu machen.
Dann war ich zu der Zeit definitiv kein normaler Benutzer.
Für so jemanden empfiehlt sich ein Zeittarif.
Minutengenaue Abrechnung der Benutzerzeit garantiert eine gute Kostenkontrolle.
Günstige Angebote haben Microsoft sowie Freenet oder Tiscali.
Tiscali sagt mir gar nichts mehr.
So Arthur Kessin vom DSL-Team.
Dass für Normal-User nicht auch ein ISDN-Anschluss ausreichend sein kann.
Also zunächst einmal muss jeder Kunde für sich entscheiden,
wie viel Zeit er ungefähr im Internet verbringt.
Denn wenn man unter 20 Stunden pro Monat unterwegs ist,
lohnt sich die Anschaffung des DSL-Anschlusses eher weniger.
Was ist das für eine bescheuere Aussage?
So, wenn ich 20 Stunden im Internet bin und möchte irgendwelche Filme gucken,
oder irgendwelche bisschen höher aufgelöste Sachen machen,
das geht mit ISDN schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Nur weil ich unter 20 Stunden drin bin, heißt das doch nicht,
dass ich viele Sachen gar nicht benutzen will.
Und gerade die Ultra-Casuals wollen doch bestimmt mal irgendwie einen neuen Filmetrailer gucken,
sogar 2002.
Das ist ja Blödsinn. Das war damals schon Blödsinnig.
Eine zweite Gruppe umfasst User, die sich im Netz gelegentlich Musik anhören, Videos anschauen...
Musik anhören?
Anhören kannst du dir mit ISDN auch nicht gescheit.
Ordentliche Bandbreite für Musik fängt ab 128... MP3, MP3.
Fängt ab 128 Kilobit an.
Und das ist schon jetzt... Also heute wird sich keiner mit 128 Kilobit MP3 anhören.
Aber ich sag mal, hörbar ordentlich ist es ab 128 Kilobit.
Und das kannst du mit ISDN nicht anhören.
Das sei denn mit Kanalbindung und sehr gut und sehr viel Glück.
Also allein schon dafür hast du damals...
Wenn du ordentlich Musik kriegst, hast du DSL gebraucht.
...surfen wollen.
Für solche Nutzer empfiehlt sich ein sogenannter Volumentarif.
Eine zeitliche Beschränkung gibt es nicht.
Jedoch darf nur eine bestimmte Menge an Daten mit dem World Wide Web ausgetauscht werden.
1 bis 5...
Und das zum Fest...
1 bis 5 Gigabyte, lol.
Da machst du...
Da machen die Boomer heute Facebook 5 mal auf und dann hast du das schon.
Na gut, übertrieben, aber geht in die Richtung.
1 Gigabyte reicht aber für bis zu 30.000 Internetseiten.
Ja.
Empfehlenswert sind hier...
Was für ein Vergleich, Mann.
Lycos, das sind die mit dem Hund, die gibt's auch nicht mehr.
Moment, Moment.
Kriegen wir da etwa File Sharing gezeigt gerade?
Kriegen wir da gerade File Sharing in einem Beitrag gezeigt?
Sehe ich das richtig, ja?
Power User.
Er lädt große Datenmengen als Video...
...oder Musikdateien auf seinen Rechnern...
Ja, ja.
Alles garantiert, ganz bestimmt, legit erworben, ja.
...oder Musikdateien auf seinen Rechnern.
Ganz bestimmt.
Solch ein Vielnutzer braucht eine Flatrate.
Ein Vielnutzer, hä?
...online zum Fixpreis.
Eine zeitliche Beschränkung gibt es nicht.
Und die Menge der transferierten Daten spielt auch keine Rolle.
Günstige Flatrates haben...
Dafür hatte ich damals 1 und 1.
Ich habe damals auch so einen Brief bekommen.
Damals hatte ich, wenn du die Flatrate viel benutzt hast,
hatte ich 1 und 1 angeschrieben und hat gefragt,
ob du nicht zu einem anderen Anbieter wechseln musst.
Und hat dir, glaube ich, sogar noch 100 Euro gegeben, wenn du wechselst.
Und in dieser Mail, äh, nicht in dieser Mail,
in diesem Brief stand sinngemäß sowas drin.
Seien wir doch mal ehrlich, das lohnt sich nicht.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Warte mal.
1 und 1 Flatrate Brief.
Mal gucken, ob es davon noch irgendwelche, äh, Flatrate Brief, äh, ähm, tja, da was suche ich denn da jetzt da?
Ähm, ist ja keine Kündigung gewesen.
Es ist, ähm, es ist auch nicht 2002 unbedingt gewesen.
Das ist schon...
Anschreiben?
Was zum?
Traue ich mich nicht aufzumachen.
Traue ich mich nicht auf.
Ähm, aber, das haben die damals verschickt, ja.
Die Online 1 und 1.
Sowie die Firma Arcor.
Doch Vorsicht.
Einige Provider mieten von der Telekom gleich die gesamte Telefonleitung mit.
Das bedeutet, dass die Dienste von Billig-Telefonanbietern, zum Beispiel für Ferngespräche, nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ich muss mir das mal auf dem zweiten Monitor angucken, ob man diese Seite, äh, gefahrlos öffnen kann, ja.
Ah, anscheinend, anscheinend kann man das gefahrlos öffnen.
Erhielt ich einen Brief?
Okay, genau, sowas, sowas in der Richtung haben die damals verschickt.
Im Rahmen einer Kostensparung, so spreche ich als Kundenbereiter gezielt, um ihnen Möglichkeiten zur Kosteneinsparung aufzusagen.
Dabei habe ich festgestellt...
Ne, das war was anderes.
Dass unsere Nutzung, damit die Betriebskosten stark strapazieren, dass sie uns nicht rechnet.
Ja, genau.
Ähm, anders führt das dazu, dass...
Wenn sie kündigen, bekommst du 100 Euro Prämie.
Genau.
Antwortfax musstest du noch unterschreiben.
Ja, sowas habe ich damals auch bekommen.
Und damals hast du das bekommen, ab...
Oder wie viel hat er verbraucht?
92 Gigabyte.
Das war damals 2005.
Unglaublich, massive, mega viel.
Ja.
Heute guckst du dir ein paar Filme an, da ist es schon durch.
Könnte man nicht kündigen oder neu bestellen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man die gebaten konnte.
Ich habe damals nicht gekündigt.
Ich bin bei denen geblieben und habe mir gedacht, das ist nicht mein Problem.
Flat ist flat.
So dachte ich mir das auch.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an hier?
Was haben wir?
Der Internetboom in Deutsch geht, das haben wir uns gerade angeschaut.
Und dann haben wir uns das hier angeschaut.
Sieben Essential-Command-Line-Tools.
Nope, nope.
Windows...
Ach ja, die CT hat ein Video dazu gemacht, ob Windows 11 sechs Monate...
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ob Windows 11 sechs Monate nach Release jetzt besser ist.
Und ich habe ja dazu auch letztens ein Video gemacht.
Und aus meiner Sicht...
Naja.
Nee.
Und mal gucken, was die CT dazu sagt.
Und die völlig kaputten Widgets.
Bleib dran.
Äh, Liebe...
In diesem Video werfen wir mal einen Blick auf Windows 11 ein halbes Jahr nach der Veröffentlichung
und schauen, welche der anfänglichen Probleme von Microsoft inzwischen behoben worden sind.
Okay, lass mich raten.
Lass mich raten.
Keins.
Oder, oder eins vielleicht.
Aber ich, ich persönlich tippe ja auf keins.
Beispiel den Gruppierungszwang in der Task-Reihe.
Oh ja, das, das habe ich ja auch in meinem Video nur zu Genüge.
Das ist, das ist so hängen geblieben.
Wer bei Microsoft hat sich das angeguckt?
Und hat gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee.
Kennst du Neues, der Anwenderkurs?
Was?
Neues, der Anwenderkurs?
Das?
Nee.
Hä?
Was sagt mir nix?
Was soll das sein?
Die Teams-Verwirrung und die völlig kaputten Widgets.
Bleib dran.
Äh, liebe Hackerin, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
...
Ja, ich sag gut, regt euch ab.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von OnlyOff, sondern ist auch komplett Open Source.
Werbung Ende.
Vor etwas mehr als einem halben Jahr ist Windows 11 offiziell veröffentlicht worden.
Ja, und ich sag mal, es war nicht das Produkt, das die Welt mit Jubelstürmen gefeiert hat.
Die Leute sind nicht...
Von was ist dieses Original-Video eigentlich?
Das habe ich schon öfters gesehen für irgendwelche Dinger.
Von, von was ist das Original-Video eigentlich?
... nicht sonderlich heiß drauf gewesen.
Und zwar auch heute noch nicht.
Schaut man sich die Zahlen von AdDuplex von April 2022 an, die 5000 Microsoft-Store-Apps ausgewertet haben, die auf Rechnern mit Windows 10 und...
Hey, die Statistik kommt mir bekannt vor.
Moment, welches Video war zuerst? Mein Video oder das CT-Video?
Mein Video war zuerst, nice.
Ähm, aber davon abgesehen, die haben natürlich alle das gleiche gesehen.
... 11 laufen. Ja, dann kommt Windows 11 nur auf einen Anteil von läppischen 20%, der Rest ist immer noch Windows 10.
Ja, und das hat keine finanziellen Gründe.
Denn das Update auf Windows 11 ist kostenlos.
Auch wenn Microsoft immer mal wieder damit gedroht hat, man müsse bis zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt updaten, danach wird es kostenpflichtig, hat Microsoft das nie durchgezogen.
Ja, das ist ja...
Auch bei Windows 10 schon nicht.
Heute lässt sich auch eine 13 Jahre alte Windows 7 Lizenz gratis auf Windows 11 upgraden.
Ja, aber viele Leute machen es trotzdem nicht.
Wir haben uns deshalb mal angeschaut, ob das gemeckert...
Die Leute hätten auch nicht auf Windows 10 upgradet, wenn sie nicht gemusst hätten.
... der ersten Monate irgendwas gebracht hat.
Das heißt, ob Microsoft die konstruktive Kritik angenommen hat.
Und Dinge behoben hat.
Auf vier Sachen haben wir uns konzentriert.
Nein. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Nummer 1. Taskleisten, Gruppierungssysteme.
Oh, ja. Nein. Das ist immer noch so.
Wenn die Zitäre...
... stellvertretend für die restliche Welt steht, dann ist das hier definitiv mit Abstand das größte Problem.
Nämlich ruft man ein Programm mehrfach auf...
Warum? Warum Microsoft?
... gleichzeitig offen hat, dann gruppiert Windows die Icons in der Taskleiste automatisch zusammen.
Das heißt, dass nur noch ein Icon zu sehen ist...
So was hängengeblieben ist.
... wenn man mit der Maus drauf geht.
Das ist übrigens auch schon in Windows 10 so.
So hängengeblieben.
Aber in Windows 10 lässt sich diese Funktion ganz einfach abstellen.
Einfach Rechtsklick auf Taskleiste...
Es ist ja okay, wenn es jemand gefällt.
Aber man sollte zumindest die Option bieten, es abzuschalten.
... dann Taskleiseneinstellungen, dann Schaltflächen der Taskleiste, gruppieren und dann auf nie.
Bei CT haben das sehr viele Leute so eingestellt.
Ja, ich auch.
Denn arbeitet man mit mehreren Dokumenten, leidet die Übersicht sonst enorm, wenn man nicht weiß, welches Dokument welches ist.
Man kann das einfach nicht richtig sehen, auch mit der Vorschau nicht.
Hier zum Beispiel bei Teams.
Welches Fenster ist jetzt nochmal welches?
Und ganz allgemein, das Umschalten dauert in der Praxis länger als bei nicht-gruppierten Icons.
In Windows 11 lässt sich das Problem mit Bordmitteln nicht beheben.
Es gibt nicht mal irgendwelche Registry-Hacks.
Will man das Verhalten ändern, braucht man zusätzliche Software.
Zum Beispiel Start11 oder StartAllBack.
Beide kosten Geld. Start11 mindestens 7,99€, StartAllBack...
Also ganz ehrlich, beides ist wahrscheinlich keine Source-Software auf Github, die würde ich mir nicht installieren.
Keine Ahnung, was ich da auf meinen Rechner hole, wenn ich den Crap installiere.
StartAllBack 4,99$.
Kostenlos ist der Explorer-Patcher auf Github.
Ich habe das mal ausprobiert.
Na super.
Aber all diese Software greift tief in eure Windows-Installation ein.
Sobald Microsoft was patcht, könnte das fiese Probleme geben.
Nur, dass ihr gewarnt seid.
Das einmal pro Jahr...
Das erinnert mich an eine Sache, die ich früher mal gemacht habe und mich super krass Hacker meldet.
Und zwar...
Ich habe mal unter Windows 98 SE die Windows 95 Explorer reingepatcht, weil in irgendeiner komischen Zeitschrift stand damals als Tipp, dass Windows 98 damit viel viel schneller ist.
Was auch stimmt, nur die Hälfte funktioniert danach nicht mehr.
Ich konnte zum Beispiel danach meine Grafikkarten-Settings nicht mehr aufmachen, weil es das Panel einfach nicht gegeben hat unter Windows 95 im Explorer.
Aber es ja der Windows 98 Treiber war.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich so Dinge gemacht habe.
Aber...
Tja...
So sieht es aus.
Planter Funktionsupdate 22H2 soll im Spätsommer für Windows 11 kommen und bislang sieht es nicht so aus...
Warum heißt das eigentlich nicht H2 22?
Das würde sich dann zweites Halb...
Weil so heißt es ja 2022 Halbjahr 2.
Ich fände zweites Halbjahr 2022 so aus.
Deutsche Aussprechweise sinnvoller.
Also 2H22.
Sortiert sich einfacher.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Da hast du recht.
Ja, dann sollte man es wahrscheinlich so lassen.
Also würde die Option...
Nein, 2H22.
2H22.
Aber ja, mit dem Sortieren ist es schon gut.
Ja, da habt ihr recht.
Gruppierungszwang zu deaktivieren.
Hier integriert werden.
Bewertung.
Microsoft hat kein bisschen reagiert auf die Kritik am Taskleisten Gruppierungszwang zu deaktivieren.
Zumindest gibt es mit dem Explorer Patcher inzwischen ein kostenloses, inoffizielles Tool.
Nummer 2.
Komplette Teamsverwirrung.
Windows 11 hat standardmäßig...
Das erste, was ich gemacht habe unter diesen paar VMs, wo wir Windows 11 ausprobiert haben, ist dieses Ding ausblenden.
Das ausblenden.
Also was ich immer ausblende.
Ich blende das aus.
Ich blende eigentlich so ziemlich alles aus, was es da unten standardmäßig gibt.
Standardmäßig ein Chat-Icon auf der Taskleiste, hinter dem sich Teams verbirgt.
Wer aber jetzt denkt, ah cool, Teams nutze ich eh, da brauche ich das nicht installieren.
Nein, Pustekuchen.
Das Vorinstallierte ist sehr wahrscheinlich nicht das Teams, das ihr beruflich benutzt.
Hä?
Was?
Man kann sich da nämlich nur mit privaten Accounts anmelden.
Ja, und man...
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Ich meine nicht, dass...
Ich habe es nie ausprobiert.
Aber warum?
Was ist denn der Sinn davon, Teams zu integrieren in Teams?
Teams zu integrieren in Windows und dann ist es nicht mal das vollständige Teams.
Alter, Microsoft, Mensch, warum macht ihr so einen Shit?
Warum?
Warum macht ihr das so unglaublich ätzend?
Warum wollt ihr, dass man abgefuckt ist, wenn man euren Kram verwendet?
Warum?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
...Accounts anmelden.
Ja, und Microsoft hat seit Neuestem noch mehr Verwirrung in petto.
Wenn man nämlich den Client herunterladen will, gibt es den einmal für zu Hause.
Moment.
Microsoft Teams auf den Windows Desktop herunterladen.
Teams für zu Hause oder kleine Unternehmen.
Teams für Berufe, Schule und Studium.
Okay, so wie ich Microsoft kenne, wird bei beidem exakt das gleiche heruntergeladen.
Aber wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen würden, dass das zwei unterschiedliche Sachen sind.
Ich hätte keine Ahnung, was ich herunterladen soll.
Soll ich jetzt...
Was ist denn das für ein widersprüchliches...
What the fuck?
Was?
Das ergibt ja überhaupt absolut gar keinen Sinn.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, was ich herunterladen soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Beruf, Schule, Studium.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Hause oder kleine Unternehmen und für Beruf, Schule und Studium.
Hä?
Das ist ja richtig hängengeblieben.
In meiner Logik würde zu Hause, Schule und Studium zusammengehören.
Und Beruf und kleine Unternehmen.
Also quasi Teams für die Freizeit und Schule und Teams für die Arbeit.
Aber für Microsoft war das offenbar zu logisch und hat das deshalb komplett verquert.
Oder die Website ist einfach nur grottenschlecht in Deutsch übersetzt.
Das kommt ja bei Microsoft auch öfters mal vor.
So dass zumindest ich nicht mehr weiß, welche Version welche ist.
Arbeite ich bei einem kleinen Unternehmen?
Zumindest laut EU-Definition sind kleine Unternehmen welche, die maximal 10 Millionen Euro Umsatz erwirtschaften.
Muss ich also jetzt wissen, wie viel Umsatz mein Arbeitgeber macht, um die richtige Teams-Version auszuwählen?
Oder wie verhält sich das?
Also wirklich jetzt mal, bei einer vorinstallierten Software bei dem populärsten Desktop-Betriebssystem der Welt,
da sollte man doch vorher vielleicht mal etwas genauer hingucken, ob das alles logisch ist für die Kundschaft.
Eigentlich ist das nämlich relativ einfach zu erklären.
Es gibt nämlich einmal das sogenannte Microsoft-Konto und einmal das sogenannte Geschäftskonto.
Das erste kann man sich als Privatmensch selbst anlegen.
Früher hieß das Windows Live-ID.
Klingt logisch.
Nur das lässt sich mit der vorinstallierten Teams-Version nutzen.
Das Geschäftskonto dagegen ist ein Konto, das von einer Administratorin oder einem Administrator erstellt wurde.
Warum?
Jetzt mal eine blöde Frage.
Warum gibt es überhaupt zwei verschiedene Teams-Versionen?
Warum kann es sich nicht einfach installieren und anhand dessen, mit was ich mich einlogge, dann die jeweiligen Funktionen anzeigen oder nicht anzeigen?
Das macht jeder so.
Warum kann das nicht Microsoft so machen?
Das funktioniert mit einem Arbeitgeber, eurer Schule oder eurer Uni.
Und das funktioniert dann mit der anderen Teams-Version.
Was ein Scheiß!
Microsoft hat hier rein gar nichts verbessert bei der Teams-Version.
Jetzt ehrlich, Teams ist definitiv nicht meine Lieblings-Version.
So schlecht!
Nummer drei, Widgets.
Ja, apropos, wenn man was macht, vielleicht kurz vorher drüber nachdenken.
Okay, Chatfrage.
Wer Windows 11 hat?
Wer verwendet diese Widgets?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es nicht schon unter Windows 11 ist.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es nicht schon unter Windows 11 irgendwelche Widgets gab.
Ich habe keine Widgets verwendet.
Äh, Windows 10.
Ich habe auch unter Windows 7 und unter Windows XP und was auch immer.
Ich habe nie Widgets verwendet.
Unter Windows.
Noch nie.
Weil ich im Prinzip mir eh sicher bin, Microsoft krempelt das laufend um und die Widgets sacken.
Die sogenannten Widgets sind standardmäßig bei Windows 11 aktiviert.
Ja.
Und es ist einfach so.
Die Widgets sind nach wie vor ein kompletter Verkehrsunfall.
Ja, Verkehrsunfall.
Das passt gut, denn hier sollten jetzt eigentlich Verkehrsmittel...
Na geil.
Das funktioniert ja wirklich erstklassig.
Super.
Toll.
Also sollten.
Stattdessen gibt es dieses geile Icon mit so einem zerrissenen Bild oder was das darstellen soll.
Das habe ich jedenfalls zum letzten Mal im Internet vor circa 150 Jahren gesehen, wenn da irgendwelche Bilder nicht richtig laden wollten.
Und ich betone nochmal.
Das ist hier jetzt nicht irgendwelche Beta-Software, sondern das ist das ganz normale Windows...
Moment, was?
Chat, das funktioniert?
Moment.
Ich verwende Windows 11 mit den Vista Sidebar Gadgets.
Das funktioniert?
Kann man unter Windows 10 auch die Vista Sidebar Gadgets verwenden?
Widget.
Gadget.
Oder auch nicht.
Auf dem aktuellen Stand an einer Gigabit-Internetleitung.
Tatsächlich taucht das Verkehrsbild dann auch...
Warum ist das so schlecht?
Ich meine ganz im Ernst.
Selbst wenn das was angezeigt hätte.
Was will ich damit?
Und zwar genau eine Minute zwanzig...
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, wie sie in diesem Windows-Präsentations-Ding die ganze Zeit erzählt haben?
So beautiful.
Und das war so richtig Apple-Style, nur in schlecht.
Das Apple-Zeug, das liefert ja meistens, wenigstens halbwegs das, was die ganzen Apple-Verfechter dann im Endeffekt haben wollen.
Aber hier, der Typ hat auch halb geweint.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran?
Windows, äh, Windows 11, äh...
Presentation.
Ja, der Typ hat halb geheult.
Der hat halb geweint in dem Livestream.
Guckt ihn euch an.
You know, a big part of defining the future is always about understanding the past.
Der, der weint gleich.
So emotional ist Windows 11.
Especially in product making.
Und when you think about...
Das ist ja zu kurz vorm Heulen, Alter.
Sad game.
...part of our lives for 35 years.
Thirty...
That's incredible, right?
35 years.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Du sagst doch, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
It's been a driving force for innovation.
It's been an enduring platform for creation.
It's been home to billions.
Der, der weint gleich.
To help us do our jobs, live our dreams and connect with people we love.
And for me...
Was, er wurde gekündigt?
Ist das T-Bait?
Wurde der wirklich rausgeschmissen?
Wenn, würde ich...
Nee, der ist immer noch da.
Der ist immer noch da.
Wie heißt der?
Pa, pa, pa...
PaSos oder irgendwie so?
Wie heißt dieser Dude?
Windows 11 Presentation Dude.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der heißt, Alter.
Wie hieß der?
Irgendwie Pa...
PaSos oder...
Nee, wie hieß der?
Geil.
Wie heißt denn der Typ?
Moment, das steht doch am Anfang bestimmt.
bestimmt. Das steht doch am Anfang.
Das steht doch bestimmt am Anfang.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Good morning. Good evening.
Good afternoon. Wherever you may be in the world,
welcome.
Panos. Panos.
Panos. Microsoft.
Nein, der ist immer noch
da. Der ist immer noch da.
Der ist immer noch da.
Alles klar.
Aber, der, der, wirklich,
ich finde das so krass, wie der halber Wein ist da.
Das ist Wahnsinn. Also,
ach, Mann.
Wo sind wir halt stehen geblieben?
Ja.
Nach dem ersten Widget-Start und
mehrmaligem Aus- und Einklappen.
So, und dann noch Microsoft,
wieso soll ich in Osterode
am Harz wohnen? Das ist von
meinem echten Standort mehr als 100
Kilometer entfernt. Und meine Adresse
habt ihr auch, weil ich sie im Microsoft
Account angegeben habe. Ja, Microsoft weiß selber nicht,
bei wie viel ihrer gesammelten Sachen,
wo was liegt. Und den könnt ihr auch mal
auslesen, weil
ja die Outlook-Termine
da auch... Also, Windows wirkt
so amateurhaft an vielen Stellen.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es unter Linux besser ist, ja.
Unter Linux hast du andere,
unter Linux hast du auch einige
Probleme, aber du hast andere Probleme, ja.
Es ist nicht alles
rosig, ja. Und unter Mac
definitiv auch nicht. Aber, was
Microsoft unter Windows macht, wirkt so
amateurhaft so. Wir doktern
irgendwo rum, wissen selber
nicht so genau, was wir machen.
Es ist, es ist wir.
Ja, und natürlich
die News in den Widgets. Das ist zu großen
Teilen der reinste Klatschpresse
Clickbait. Dieter Bohlen, die ganze
Wahrheit über sein DSDS-Comeback,
ja, da habe ich schon, das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen.
Und man kann zwar auf keine News
mehr von XY anzeigen.
Wundervibe. Okay.
Wieder was gelernt. Es gibt eine
Webseite, die so heißt. Nur wird das halt
sehr oft ignoriert, sodass man den Kram
immer noch sehen muss. Egal, wie oft man
das anklickt. Abhilfe, Rechtsklick
auf die Taskleiste,
Widgets, hier auf, aus.
Und weg ist der Kram komplett. Chat auch aus.
Wird niemand vermissen. Chat auch gleich ausschalten.
Das geht übrigens genauso mit diesem komischen
Chat, aka Teams
für zu Hause oder kleine Unternehmen.
Kann man auch einfach mit Click wegmachen.
Bewertung, es hat sich nichts geändert
mit den schrottigen Widgets.
Nummer 4, Kontozwang.
Ich hatte ja Anfang schon gesagt, ein Windows 11
Update klappt mit ewig alten
Windows-Lizenzen. Microsoft scheint also
mit Privatleuten die Windows 11
nicht verdienen zu wollen.
Sondern das Geld kommt von PC-Herstellern
und Unternehmen. Und langfristig
will Microsoft... Mit dem nächsten Update
ist angeblich unter Windows Professional
auch so ohne weiteres nicht mehr möglich
einen Offline-Account zu verwenden.
Ich krieg echt Aggression, wenn ich mir
dieses
Gegängele und
und amateurhafte
Rumgefrickel
von Microsoft angucke.
Ich krieg da
richtig Ausschlag bei.
Weil es mich
abfuckt,
wenn ich mehr Aufwand
habe durch Sachen,
die nicht sein müssten.
Ich krieg immer wieder Anfälle, wenn Sachen
an irgendwelchen Stellen angepasst werden,
weil sich irgendeiner gedacht hat,
ah ja, das muss jetzt sein.
Und ich mich dann wieder komplett
mir was überlegen muss, wie krieg ich es jetzt
wieder gescheit integriert. Das ist so
abartig, Alter.
Lieber Geld mit seinen Office-Abos
und seinem App-Store, genannt Microsoft-Store.
Ja, den haben sie jetzt ja umbenannt
und er ist jetzt natürlich viel besser, der App-Store.
Möglichst alle dazu gezwungen werden,
einen Microsoft-Account zu verwenden.
Ohne Account keine Software-Verkäufe oder Abos.
Tja, und während in den Anfangszeiten von
Windows 11 nur bei der Installation von
Windows 11 Home so lange gemeckert wurde,
bis man einen Account angegeben oder
angelegt hat, wird es künftig auch bei der
Pro-Version so sein. Bislang konnte man da
ganz offiziell Offline-Konten anlegen.
Als Trick klappt bislang noch,
mehrfach eine falsche E-Mail-Adresse anzugeben,
aber die Frage ist, wie lange noch?
Bewertung, der Account-Zwang wird
künftig eher noch schlimmer als besser.
Mein Fazit, von den häufig kritisierten
Windows-Problembereichen, also
die Sachen, die ihr hier so kommentiert oder
die sonst die CT-Redaktion so erreicht,
hat Microsoft einfach im ersten
halben Jahr gar nichts verweigert.
Nix? Dachte ich mir. Habe ich auch richtig gelegen am Anfang,
oder? Dass nix gefixt wurde.
Ganz schön schade. Stattdessen gibt es
im für den Spätsommer geplanten ersten
Feature-Update, auch bekannt als
22H2,
irgendwelche ganz anderen Detail-Verbesserungen
nach denen niemand... Gibt's da überhaupt
Verbesserungen? Eine kleinere Task-Leiste
für Tablets.
Wow!
Da habe ich drauf gewartet.
Endlich!
Microsoft,
aber huge
Verbesserung. Das haben wir gebraucht.
Alter, Poggers!
Oder, dass die Boot-Animation
wieder geändert wurde.
Das sieht doch so aus.
Statt dem hier, gibt's jetzt das hier.
Haha!
Geil, Microsoft! Da hat die Welt...
Haha! Warum?
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Warum? Warum doktern
die an so einem Shit rum, man?
Ich meine, das wäre nicht schlimm.
Ohne Scheiß, ich habe damit überhaupt kein Problem.
Das können die machen, wenn...
wenn das Bestandteil
ist von irgendeinem sinnvollen Update.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme damit,
wenn die die Boot-Animation irgendwie verschönern
oder was auch immer.
Aber du kannst doch nicht sagen, okay...
Es ist immer noch...
Scheiße. Und wir kacken
auf unsere User. Wir geben
einen Scheiß drauf komplett.
Was man ja sieht am Online-Account
zwang.
Und dann, ja, im nächsten
Update gibt's zwar nix von dem, was
ihr haben wollt, aber es gibt jetzt
einen Kreis anstatt Punkte bei einer Boot-Animation.
Ja, geil!
Und das ist auch alles ganz nett, aber
besser wäre es doch, erstmal die von der
Kundschaft geforderten Sachen zu fixen.
Oder? Obwohl ich dir natürlich
den Finger in die Wunde lege,
wäre ich Windows 11 dennoch...
Wir werden alle früher oder später Windows 11
brauchen, weil Microsoft
wird sicherlich dafür sorgen, dass neue
Sachen, so wie gesagt mit Direct Storage
und so fängt's jetzt an,
nicht mehr gescheit unter Windows
10, wenn überhaupt,
wenn sie überhaupt existieren,
wird's das nicht mehr gescheit geben. Also,
spätestens im Jahr oder so müssen wir wahrscheinlich alle
umsteigen.
Windows 10 und benutze das privat
auch noch als Hauptbetriebssystem.
Vor allem, weil es einfach deutlich
moderner aussieht als Windows.
Windows 10 und sich schwuppsiger anfühlt.
Vor allem ist Windows 10 keine langfristige
Alternative, denn es wird nur bis Oktober
2025 Updates geben.
Aber wie schon gesagt, Microsoft sollte
vielleicht in Zukunft besser auf die Kundschaft
hören, denn der Windows-Marktanteil
sinkt seit Jahren stetig.
Und mit Linux, MacOS,
Leute, nächstes
Jahr, wenn ich das so sehe,
wisst ihr, was nächstes Jahr ist?
Ihr wisst genau.
2023, was wird das sein?
Das Jahr des?
Ihr wisst schon.
Das Jahr des
Linux-Desktops.
Genau. So wie die letzten
30 Jahre auch. Okay, 20.
20 Jahre.
Aber vielleicht schaffen wir die 1%
immerhin.
Und mit Linux,
MacOS und ChromeOS
gibt es starke Alternativen.
Tschüss.
Alter, ich muss
jetzt das Thema wechseln, weil
bei diesem Thema
rege ich mich immer viel zu sehr auf.
Ja.
Gigachat-Linux-User.
Und du hast es richtig gemacht, weil
ansonsten hättest du nicht
GNU-Linux geschrieben,
wisst ihr ja genau,
was dann passiert wäre,
wenn du einfach nur Linux geschrieben hättest.
Korrekt.
Das wäre
dann passiert.
Windows 11 Event Supercut.
Gaming.
Skyrim.
Das hat mich ja damals auch, da mussten wir auch
ordentlich kecken, als sie ernsthaft
Skyrim gezeigt haben in Windows 10.
Ey, Windows 11. Hör ich euch an?
Skyrim. Hättet ihr nix irgendwie noch
was annähernd modernes zeigen können?
Games.
Das war großartig.
Naja.
Oh Mann.
Ok, das schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Komm, können wir noch was.
Warte, ich bin schon 2 Stunden und 46 чтоn, ich hab Hunger, aber
was gucken wir.
Eine Sache können wir uns noch angucken.
Wir könnten uns mal wieder so ein
Lohnt sich das angucken, die find ich immer gut gemacht.
Lohnt sich das?
Also, was lohnt sich denn heute?
Sanitär, Heizungs- und Klimatechnik
Was, warum der Metaverse-Hype dumm ist?
Weil der Zuck das erzählt hat
Und wenn der Zuck was erzählt, dann ist das in der Regel mit Vorsicht zu genießen
Weißt du, warum Willi Piet Kast...
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Ich habe auch schon ewig nichts mehr von ihm gehört
Absolut keine Ahnung, warum der aufgehört hat
Debian oder Arch, by the way
Also, komm, jetzt
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Nix Debian
Arch
Wobei, ich muss sagen
Jetzt mal
Arch, by the way, Meme außen vor
Ich verwende aktuell noch Manjaro
Da sagen ja die richtigen Arch-Kenner
Dass das ja auch kein richtiges Arch-Linux ist
Und auf den meisten Systemen, wo ich es mir aussuchen kann
Server-Technik
Läuft Ubuntu-Server drauf
Außer auf den Raspberry Pis
Da läuft natürlich
Raspbian heißt ja nicht mehr
Raspberry Pi OS drauf, was ein Debian ist
Also eigentlich ist meine Mischung aus Linux daheim
Manjaro auf dem Desktop
Debian auf den Raspberry Pis
Und Ubuntu auf allen anderen Dingern
Und auch auf den Cloud-VMs
Also ist mein Stack quasi
Können wir da irgendwas Gescheites haben?
Upp
Upp-D
Upp-Dema
Der Upp-Dema-Stack
Also ich verwende den Upp-Dema-Stack
Daheim
Mittlerweile, du musst das alles in so coole Abkürzungen
Machen heutzutage
Und Stack dahinter schreiben
Also
Was meint ihr eben, sollte ich mal
Warum Metaverse-Hype dumm ist
Und es niemals kommen wird
Ja
Dann erzähl mal
Der macht ja teilweise nice Videos
Wir haben ja schon ein paar von ihm geguckt
Weil da durchaus sind coole Sachen dabei
Ähm
Guck mal
Ist der Ubuntu-Server auf dem Raspberry Pi brauchbar?
Äh
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
Ob ich Ubuntu schon einmal auf dem Raspberry Pi
Doch hab ich
Ja, geht
Aber es gab ein paar Sachen, die mich genervt haben
Warum ich wieder Raspbian drauf gemacht hab
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht mehr sicher
Was der Grund war, warum ich Ubuntu drauf gemacht hatte
Es hatte
Es hat wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Grund gehabt
Ich weiß es aber nicht mehr
Aber du hast mit Raspbian mehr oder weniger alles
Was du brauchst
So, zeig mal her
Hast du dir das mit dem iPad Pro und Raspberry Pi von Techcraft schon angefordert?
Ne, schick mal einen Link
Der Hype um das Metaverse ist lächerlich dumm
Aber fangen wir mal vorne an
Erst Anfang des Jahres hat Montana Black Werbung gemacht
Für einen Hitler-Gut
Na gut
Montana Black macht auch Werbung für komische Glücksspiel-Seiten
Also da würde ich jetzt nicht so viel drauf geben
Wenn da Werbung dafür macht
Inklusive unzensierter Hakenkreuz-Armbindel
Hä?
Das ist doch alte News
Das hab ich doch schon gemacht
Das hab ich doch schon im Podcast Lester-Schwestern gehört
Und ich dachte, es geht hier darum, wie dumm der Hype um das Metaverse ist
Was hat das jetzt mit einem Nazi-Gorilla zu tun?
Tja, auf der Website des Kondo-Clubs
Also der Gorilla-NFT-Kollektion, um die es hier geht
Wird unter anderem damit geworben
Moment, Moment, das ist nicht
Das ist nicht der Bord-Elb-Jacht-Club
Das ist wieder was anderes, oder?
Also dieses NF...
Okay, weiter
Dass der Hitler-Gorilla ready ist fürs Metaverse
Und das ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
MontanaBlack musste sich nicht nur für den Hakenkreuz-Tweet entschuldigen
Sondern auch für Werbung für einen anderen NFT
Der angeblich ein Scam sein soll
Squiggles
Und was findet man auf der Squiggles-Webseite?
Metaverse-Ready-Gegen
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin mir da noch nicht mal selbst sicher
Ob der das aus eigenem Antrieb postet
Oder ob er halt irgendwelche Beratungsleute hat
Die sagen, hier guck mal
Was auch immer
Keine Ahnung, ob er da selbst immer auch drauf kommt
Gut, nichtsdestotrotz
Wenn so ein Antrieb ist, dann ist das nicht so
Wenn man das auf einem Account postet
Dann mitgehangen, mitgefangen
Keine Ahnung
Unge hat Kritik dafür abbekommen
Dass er sich für über 40.000
Dann machen die Berater den Job nicht gut
Da werden sie nicht die Ersten
1000 Euro einen Azuki-Zen-NFT gekauft hat
Und was ist das Azuki-Zen-Motto?
Eine Marke fürs Metaverse
Eines der größten Metaverse-Projekte aktuell
Heißt Decentraland
Die Währung da ist ein Krypto-
Wisst ihr, was ich da ein bisschen
Ich hab mit überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit
Dass Leute Werbung machen
Ja
Null
Und dass sie dafür ordentlich bezahlt werden
Auch null
Weil gerade, wenn du hunderttausende Viewer hast
Natürlich musst du ordentlich bezahlt werden
Das ist nicht
Billig
Also allein schon, wenn ich teilweise angucke, was ich
Und ich bin ja weit davon entfernt, sowas in dieser Richtung zu haben
Teilweise Angebote bekommen, ist schon nicht schlecht
Wobei ich vieles davon nicht mache
Und wenn du umso größer du bist, umso krasser ist es
Aber, was ich bei dieser ganzen Werbung
Immer ein bisschen doof finde
Wenn das so quasi komplett ohne nachzugucken passiert
Weil sowohl Unge als auch Montana Black
Und wer auch sonst wie von den größeren Influencers
Die haben auch gerade bei denen ist es so
Dass es da viele gibt, die die Sachen quasi fressen
Ohne sich irgendwie selbst Gedanken drüber zu machen
Das sind gar nicht mal unbedingt, weil man immer sagt
Das sind die Jüngere
Ich würde mal sagen, es gibt genauso viele Jüngere
Die nicht richtig denken können wie Ältere
Bei Älteren kommt dann halt noch die Erfahrung dazu
Dass sie irgendwann vielleicht mal feststellen
Okay, nicht jeder da sagt, er macht mich reich
Macht mich auch wirklich reich
Das muss man vielleicht auch erst mal lernen
Aber, dass es dann sehr viele Leute quasi fressen
Diese Geschichte mit
Oh, geiles NFT, cooles Zeug
Und hier und da und da alles ganz toll
Und die Zukunft und sonst wie
Obwohl die sich eigentlich selbst
Außer, dass die Montana Black oder Unge cool finden
Finden sie jetzt halt auch
NFTs neuerdings geil
So, warum? Keine Ahnung, weil es Montana Black oder Unge gepostet hat
Die etwas Älteren, die blöd sind
Haben halt vielleicht irgendwann mal schon gelernt
Dass es nicht so gut ist, jedem nachzurennen
Der sagt, er macht dich reich
Aber, deswegen denke ich halt, dass gerade Jüngere
Dafür empfänglich sind
Wobei ich, wie gesagt
Diese Sache, was immer erzählt wird
Ja, das sind immer Jüngere, die sind ja
Als wären die Jüngeren blöder
Das würde ich so gar nicht mitgehen
Ich würde sagen, es gibt genug schlaue Leute, die auch jünger sind
Aber, gerade was so Scams angeht
Und dass du nicht blind alles fressen darfst
Was irgendwelche
Bezugs, ja, Personen
Oder wie man sie nennen mag, die dir vorkauen
Das muss man wahrscheinlich mit Erfahrung
Mit der Zeit auch ein bisschen lernen
So, gucken wir mal
Und die Grundstücke sind
You guessed it, NFTs
Okay, aber was sind denn jetzt?
Das ist fast so geil wie dieser Scam
Habe ich jetzt auch ein paar mal gesehen
Du kannst dir angeblich jetzt Land in Schottland kaufen
Also irgendwie so ein Quadratmeter Land in Schottland
Kannst du dir kaufen
Und kannst dann dafür dir den Titel Lord oder Lady eintragen lassen
Was totaler Schwachsinn ist
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht
Also du besitzt weder dieses Land
Also es ist nicht etwa so, dass du da hingehen könntest
Und sagen, ich stelle mich jetzt auf mein Land drauf
Kannst du nicht
Diese Länder werden sogar shared
Also diese Anbieter haben
Keine Ahnung, fünf Flächen
Und die werden dann mehrere Leute quasi
Verkauft
Und das einzige, was du bekommst
Ist ein Zertifikat
Du kannst dir nirgendwo diesen Titel eintragen lassen
Es ist auch kein echter Titel
Und wenn du es wirklich versuchst
Ist das Betrug
Ja
Also wenn du wirklich draufschreiben sollst
Das ist wie, dass du irgendwie
Bei manchen irgendwie Doktor wirst
Oder Prinz wirst
Oder was auch immer
Wenn du versuchst dir dann mit diesem Titel
Quasi noch was zu erschleichen
Das ist Betrug
Und das Internet ist so krass
Voller Scams an allen Enden
Und irgendwie haben es immer noch
Zu wenig Leute gecheckt
Ich meine immerhin, Gott sei Dank
Haben es die Leute
Und das ist jetzt ein bisschen weniger geworden
Haben es die Leute ja mittlerweile gecheckt
Dass wenn irgendein Typ mit einem fetten Auto
Um die Ecke gefahren kommt
Und erstmal den hier macht
Hier Leute, ich versuch mal kurz Sachen zu machen
Erstmal den hier macht
Mit ein paar Geldscheinen
So, ja
Aus dem Auto raus
Und dann sagt
Hier bei mir lernt ihr wie ihr reich werdet
Nur ich weiß Bescheid
Das haben die Leute glaube ich ja mittlerweile gecheckt
Dass das eher nicht so gut klappt
Aber die restlichen Sachen klappen trotzdem noch
Ey
Ist dieser Streaming-Tool
Ist dieser Streamer
Ist dieser Scam
Das ist die krasseste Abo-Falle
Die ihr euch vorstellen könnt
Nur mit dem Unterschied
Dass ihr plus IQ-Punkte bekommt für jeden Sub
Auch kein Scam
Garantiert
Nf t
Nf t steht für non fungible token
Das heißt
Nicht austauschbar
Einzigartig sozusagen
Die Idee ist digitalen Dingen
Die ja immer leicht kopierbar sind
Die selbe einzigartigkeit zu geben
Wie physischen Dingen
Why?
Because money
Es gibt nur eine echte Mona Lisa
Aber ein Foto von der Mona Lisa
Kann ich
Also, NFTs ist das, was das Wort sagt. Das ist ein Token. Das ist irgendein Hash-Wert. Das hat erstmal prinzipiell nichts damit zu tun, was man so an Grafiken sieht. Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre irgendwie ein Affe da drin gespeichert oder so.
Ich würde mich oft kopieren, wenn ich aber in das Excel-Dokument reinschreibe, dass mir...
Deswegen sind ja auch einige dieser ganzen angeblichen Krypto- und NFT-Projekte, die es da so gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit ihr das kennt. Ich will das nicht zu sehr ausholen.
Es gibt ja die ein oder anderen Projekte, die zum Beispiel sagen, du kannst dir...
So, Earth2. Habt ihr Earth2 mitbekommen?
Das ist ein Projekt, das verkauft dir virtuelles Land.
Also quasi so Blockchain, Krypto, NFT.
So, da kannst du dir virtuelles Land kaufen.
Da kannst du dir zum Beispiel England kaufen oder sowas.
Man hat es davon abgesehen, das grundsätzliche Problem ist, dem gehört ja England nicht mal.
Da können die das verkaufen.
Also der verkauft dir quasi auf einer virtuellen Karte virtuelles Land.
Und das kannst du dir dann da kaufen.
So, und bei einigen dieser Projekte, die was von wegen Krypto und NFT und Blockchain...
...gefaselt haben, kam jetzt im Endeffekt raus, diese Projekte sind eine ganz simple Postgres-Datenbank.
Nix Blockchain, nix NFT, nix Krypto.
Einfach eine stinknormale Postgres-Datenbank.
Wer hätte das so denken können, dass das Scam ist?
Also da ist beim Krypto gar nix Krypto bei vielen dieser Dinger.
Aber die Leute stecken da Millionen teilweise rein.
Das ist mir absolut...
Macht's wie ich, Leute.
Kauft euch von eurem Geld Stonks.
Und macht...
Sekunde.
Und macht den letzten Monat über minus 1577,69 Euro minus.
Das ist...
So muss das machen.
Okay, weiter.
Spezifische digitale Mona Lisa gehört.
Dann kann ich damit angeben gehen.
Kopieren kann man sie trotzdem noch.
Aber man kann angeben.
Und das ist tatsächlich der häufigste...
Die Mona Lisa wird es als NFT geben.
Dann heißt das nicht, dass du dir das Ding mit nach Hause nehmen kannst.
Es heißt noch nicht mal, dass du irgendwie Sonderzutrittsrechte in den Raum hast, wo das hängt oder so.
Das heißt im Prinzip gar nix.
Außer, dass du irgendwo im Internet steht, dass du die Mona Lisa hast.
Das ergibt...
Jetzt die Frage ist, was halt dranhängt.
Du kannst dann quasi überweisen.
Ja, du bist der Besitzer.
Du bist der Besitzer dieses Tokens.
Okay.
Aber welche Rechte mit diesem Token verknüpft sind, ist ja die eigentliche Frage.
Und meistens gar keine.
Beziehungsweise Sachen, die andere nicht können.
Also, es ergibt so keinen Sinn, wie es aktuell ist, außer um die Leute zu scammen.
Nächster Anwendungsbereich von NFTs.
Rechte überträgt man damit übrigens nicht, wie in diesem Fall von einem Froscharsch, den ein Künstler als NFT verkauft hat.
Aber weil er weiterhin das Urheberrecht am Bild hatte, konnte er noch mehr Froscharsch-NFTs daraus machen,
was den Typen, der den Froscharsch für eine halbe Million gekauft hat...
Was? Eine halbe Million, Alter?
...gefallen hat. Und das, Kinder, sind NFTs.
Kann man nicht mehrere Tokens für ein Objekt erstellen?
Natürlich kannst du das.
Du kannst so viele Tokens erstellen, wie du lustig bist,
weil das Token erstmal mit dem Bild absolut gar nichts zu tun hat.
Eine Besitzurkunde ist was anderes.
Eine Besitzurkunde bedeutet ja auch wirklich, dass dir das Ding gehört.
Also, da könntest du das wahrscheinlich, solange du nicht vertraglich irgendwelche Verbindungen eingehst.
Also, wenn du jetzt den Museum...
Wenn du mit dem Museum einen Vertrag unterschrieben hast,
dass du ihnen das für ein halbes Jahr zur Ausstellung überlässt,
dann kannst du es nicht einfach abhängen.
Aber ansonsten kannst du das einpacken, mitnehmen und bei dir daheim hinhängen, wenn dir das gehört.
Wenn du Besitzer davon bist, von wirklich von diesem Gemälde,
kannst du das machen, was du bei einem NFT nicht machen kannst.
Weil das Einzige, was dir wirklich gehört bei einem NFT, ist im Endeffekt der Hash-Wert, der Token.
Und nachdem das Bild erstmal nichts mit dem Token zu tun hat,
ist das ziemlich unsinnig.
Deswegen kann ich auch auf irgendeine x-beliebige File-Sharing-Seite gehen
und mir alle Affen-NFTs runterladen.
Die habe ich dann, die kann ich in meinem Twitter-Avatar machen oder sonst wo.
Wo es anfängt, interessant zu werden.
Wobei man sagen muss, da ist dann aber auch fraglich, ob das Krypto-Blockchain-NFT sein muss.
Wo es anfängt, interessant zu werden, aber so weit sind wir irgendwie witzigerweise nicht,
weil die Leute ja erstmal gescampt werden müssen.
Wo es anfängt, interessant zu werden, ist...
Wenn du diese Tokens quasi als Ausweis verwendest und Anbieter dann quasi darauf aufsetzen, Sachen implementieren.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt YouTube sagt oder Twitter, Twitter macht ja sowas teilweise schon.
Wenn YouTube und Twitter beispielsweise eine Avatar-Funktion einbaut, wo du checken kannst,
wo du das verbinden kannst mit irgendwelchen Blockchains, fragt mich nicht genau, wie man das machen würde.
Und dann gecheckt wird so nach dem Motto, okay, der Account-Besitzer hat sich quasi authentifiziert,
dass er quasi dieses Wallet oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das da genau nennt, Twitter hat sowas mittlerweile,
dass das diesem Account-Besitzer zugeordnet werden kann und dort ist dann quasi hinterlegt,
dass der das und das gekauft hat.
Und aufgrund dessen zeigen wir jetzt Avatar XY an.
Sowas in der Richtung mit Integration.
Ja, aber das bedeutet noch lange nicht, dass dann in diesem Token das gespeichert ist,
sondern nur, dass der Anbieter was zusätzliches anzeigt aufgrund diesem Token.
Also das eine hat mit dem anderen gar nicht so viel zu tun.
Das ist dann wieder Implementierungsfrage.
Neue Goldrush aus den letzten Monaten.
Und das hat dann auch dazu geführt, dass jeder jetzt alles als NFT verkaufen will.
Zum Beispiel die Associated Press, die dachte, es wäre super hip,
Bilder von Geflüchteten, kurz von Ersaufen, als NFT anzubieten.
Oder mein persönlicher Lieblings-NFT Digi...
Serious, das gab's?
Also, da müsste doch, glaube ich, auch...
Also der Typ, der hinter diesem Twitter-Account steht,
der muss doch beim Schreiben dieser Meldung
ganz tief hinten in seinem Hirn, muss doch irgendjemand,
irgendetwas, so eine innere Stimme gesagt haben,
das ist wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Oder mein persönlicher Lieblings-NFT Digitale Fürze,
weil die Influencerin, die vorher ihre Fürze in echt abgefüllt und verkauft hat,
davon krank wurde, dass sie für die Fürze so ungesund essen musste...
Das ist ja noch besser als Gamer Girl Badewasser.
Es wird ja immer schlimmer, Alter.
Es wird ja immer schlimmer.
Sag mal, Chat, ich hab den Eindruck, wir sind die einzige High-IQ...
Wie sagt man?
Bastion, die es im Internet noch gibt, wenn ich mir diesen Scheiß angucke.
Deswegen gucken in letzter Zeit auch so viele Leute zu,
weil hier High-IQ-Leute unter sich sind.
Keine Ahnung, aber ganz ehrlich, du zweifelst doch wirklich,
also nicht nur am Verstand der Leute, am Verstand zweifel ich ja schon länger,
aber auch an allen sonstigen Skills der Menschheit so langsam, oder?
Das ist doch alles nicht mehr normal.
Dass es die jetzt nur noch digital gibt, okay, aber das klingt doch echt ziemlich dumm.
Das kann doch nicht lange gut gehen.
Äh, okay.
Es wirkt also inzwischen ein bisschen so, als wäre die Stimmung zu Krypto und zu NFTs ein bisschen gekippt.
Es reicht nicht mehr, dass man mit NFTs nur angeben kann.
Einfach irgendwo einen Eintrag zu haben, der sagt, dass man etwas besitzt,
ist nicht genug, um zu garantieren, dass der Preis immer weiter steigt.
Aber was, wenn es einen mystischen digitalen Ort gebe, wo ich meine NFTs tatsächlich nutzen kann?
Ein Ort, der mehr ist als eine Online-Tauschbörse für JPEG.
Er will ja die Überleitung zum Metaverse machen.
Wundersamer Platz, wo ich meine digitale Kunst auch tatsächlich ausstellen kann,
wie in einem eigenen Haus.
Wow!
Herzlich willkommen zu dem Grund, warum das Metaverse in der Krypto-Community so gehypt wird.
Das ist einfach, um mehr NFTs zu verkaufen.
Ja, aber daran sieht man schon mal, das ist eine ziemlich gute Erklärung an der Stelle,
woran man sieht, dass das eigentliche Token
mit dem, was man im Kopf damit verknüpft, gar nichts zu tun hat.
Weil den Token kannst du heute schon erwerben,
aber irgendjemand muss erst hingehen, sich hinsetzen, ein Metaverse programmieren,
Content dafür erstellen, dass du mit deinen Tokens dann darin was anzeigen kannst.
Also daran sieht man, dass das eine mit dem anderen erst einmal gar nichts zu tun hat.
Weil ansonsten könnte ich das erste ja nicht schon kaufen,
während das andere vielleicht irgendwann einmal da ist.
Ja, aber was ist das Metaverse?
Oh, das ist einfach. Ich habe da nämlich neulich ein paar Überschriften gesehen,
wie Kaufland mit seiner eigenen Insel ins Metaverse startet.
Kaufland treibt die Expansion des Handels ins Metaverse.
Ja, das ist wie damals BMW auch irgendeine Filiale in Second Life aufgemacht hat,
weil irgendein Manager damals mitbekommen hat, das ist hip
und dabei war es eigentlich schon überhaupt nicht mehr hip.
Wow, also ich wusste überhaupt nicht, dass wir schon so weit sind beim Metaverse.
Das gibt es schon? Und Kaufland ist da?
Ne, ist doch nicht.
Ja, Kaufland hat einfach eine Twitch-Streamerin bezahlt,
ihnen eine Insel im Spiel Animal Crossing New Horizons zu bauen.
Die Agentur, die sich das...
Alter, also jetzt machst du erstmal ernsthaft.
Um aus der eigentlichen Nachricht diese Überschrift zu machen,
da musst du schon weit,
großen Gedankensprung machen, ja?
Ne, ist doch nicht.
Ja, Kaufland hat einfach eine Twitch-Streamerin bezahlt,
ihnen eine Insel im Spiel Animal Crossing New Horizons zu bauen.
Die Agentur, die sich das ausgedacht hat, hat einfach gesagt, das wäre das Metaverse.
Da musst du schon wirklich absoluter Eleven-Header sein,
um von einer Animal-Crossing-Insel zu Metaverse...
Kaufland hat einen Metaverse-Stand.
Medien, das ist völlig unkritisch übernommen.
Ich meine, nichts gegen Animal Crossing, ist ein tolles Spiel,
aber es ist eine Sache auf keinen Fall, das Metaverse.
Das ist einfach nur ein Spiel, das nicht mal VR kann,
mit ein bisschen gestalterischer Freiheit.
Und ein Spiel, wohlgemerkt, wohlgemerkt,
mit einem Kack-Online-Modus.
Nintendo-Style, verschissene Multiplayer.
Also, das ist, wenn es ein...
Dann ist es auch im Kernaspekt, nämlich Online und Multiplayer,
ein äußerst, äußerst schlechtes Metaverse.
Jetzt einen Charakter erstellen, den Rob Bubble nennen
und da eine Pressemitteilung raushauen.
Rob Bubble ist der erste YouTuber im Metaverse.
Auf geht's.
Krass.
Warte mal, heißt das, dass vieles über das Metaverse aktuell Bullshit ist?
Was?
Ich habe jetzt schon mein ganzes erspartes Geld
in Metaverse-ready NFTs gesteckt.
Wir müssen mal kurz Werbung machen, sorry.
Kennen Sie das?
Sie haben das gesamte ersparte Geld Ihrer Familie in wertlose NFTs gesteckt.
Aber dann kam das Metaverse gar nicht.
Und jetzt müssen Sie vor Ihrer wütenden Frau ins Ausland fliehen?
Aber ich habe doch überhaupt nicht genug Geld, um das Land zu verlassen.
Ja, kein Problem. Mit NordVPN können Sie einfach so tun,
als wären Sie in einem anderen Land.
Ich bin gerade in Amerika.
Das ist ja viel geiler als das Metaverse.
Da gibt es sogar schon Content, der existiert und fertig ist.
Ich kann zum Beispiel...
Muss es NordVPN sein, wirklich, ja.
Die wegen Geoblocking hier sonst gar nicht verfügbar wären.
Und ich kann dank NordVPN in meinem WLAN von meiner Frau verstecken,
dass ich gerade schon wieder...
Was machst du da?
Äh, nix.
NordVPN ist dabei eine der schnellsten VPNs überhaupt
und funktioniert auf allen Geräten.
Auch für meine Meta-Quest 2?
Nein, dafür ist es aber auf dem Handy
und auf bis zu sechs Geräten gleichzeitig nutzbar.
Der integrierte NordVPN-Bedrohungsschutz kann außerdem dabei helfen,
dass zum Beispiel Werbetracker und Robots blockiert werden.
Von einem Scam zum anderen.
Ähm, eine Sache funktioniert ja bei den VPN-Dingern wirklich.
Du kannst damit höchstwahrscheinlich,
bis die Anbieter wieder rumdricksen,
äh, Geoblocking umgehen.
Okay, ja, das ist richtig.
Der Rest ist Blödsinn.
Also, die schützen dich weder gescheit vor Online-Trackern,
wie sollen sie das machen,
noch schützen sie dich irgendwie vor Werbung
oder noch schützen sie dich vor Schadsoftware.
Wie soll es auch funktionieren?
Ich meine, dein Stream ist end-zu-ende verschlüsselt über HTTPS.
Könnt ihr da gar nicht reingucken.
VPN.com slash robbubble.
Kriegt ihr den Zwei-Jahres-Plan mit einem riesigen Rabatt,
inklusive einem kostenlosen Monat.
Das sind nur 2,77 Euro monatlich.
Probiert das ohne Risiko mal aus, dank der 30-Tage-Garantie.
Die machen DNS-App-Blocking.
Ja, das geht.
Das ist auch das Einzige, was mir einfällt, was funktionieren könnte.
Fiktion-Roman namens Snow Crash, der erst 30 Jahre alt ist.
Die machen Man-in-the-Middle-Gedöns.
Wie sollen die Man-in-the-Middle machen?
Mit einer HTTPS-Verbindung zu, keine Ahnung,
mit einem Google-Web-Server.
Die können bestimmt nicht Man-in-the-Middle
für einen Google-Web-Server machen.
Und wenn, dann würde ich mir ernsthafte Gedanken machen.
Ein bisschen MMORPG wie World of Warcraft,
aber mit beliebigen Avataren.
Und ein ganz schlechter Avatar vom Zug auf, äh ...
Tja, ich fand diese ...
Habt ihr auch diese vom Zuckerberg,
oder vom Zuckerberg, muss man ja sagen,
diese Metaverse-Gedöns,
hab ich in der Max-Geschichte gesehen,
wo er da mit seinem 3D-Avatar rumgerannt ist.
Ich fand das so zum Fremdschämen.
Und das hat sich so ...
so wirr angefühlt, so irgendwie ...
Was will er uns eigentlich damit sagen?
Und warum sollte ich das benutzen wollen?
Und was ist das überhaupt, was du mir hier zeigen willst?
Das hier meine ich.
Ja, ja, genau, das hier meine ich, ja.
Wie in Ready Player One,
dann aus unterschiedlichen Franchises, also Kostüme ...
Ich kann mich gar nicht dran erinnern.
... einen digitalen Charakter wie in Fortnite,
oder eben wie in Hitler-Gorilla.
Was übrigens der Grund ist, warum vor ein paar Jahren
Leute gesagt haben, Fortnite wäre das Metaverse,
weil man da als Darth Vader neben Deadpool,
neben Charakteren aus Dune rumrennen kann.
Oh nein, ist das Metaverse.
Naja, wenn's danach geht,
wenn's danach geht, ist jedes MMO das Metaverse.
Keine Ahnung ...
Das ist wieder so ein Buzzword, wo keiner so ...
... richtig griffig und greifbar ist.
Das hat irgendjemand sich jetzt ausgedacht,
und jetzt kann man machen, was man will, so.
Das Metaverse ist aber eigentlich nicht nur als Spiel gedacht,
sondern auch für Arbeitsmeetings, zum Treffen von Freunden ...
Oh, da gibt's was Cooles.
Das möchte bei mir auf der Arbeit keiner haben,
aber ich fänd's geil, wenn wir's hätten.
Ähm, Work Adventure?
Das da?
Nee.
Ach Mensch, nee, wie heißt das?
Oder doch?
Wurde so ein Pixel ...
Doch, genau das!
Das find ich so nice!
Wo du quasi so ...
Wo du in so einer Pixelwelt rumlaufen kannst,
und wenn du dann in den Raum reingehst,
zu irgendeiner Besprechung,
dann geht da Voice Chat an.
Das find ich cool.
Aber das hat keine Integration mit Teams,
dementsprechend keine Chance bei uns.
Da sind wir, glaub ich, auch nicht agil dafür.
... Events und als grundlegender Ersatz für Social Media,
und das gesamte Internet.
Und dann am besten auch noch ...
Okay, Chat, ich muss mal kurz
meiner Informationspflicht nachkommen im Chat.
Max, was wäre aus deiner Sicht ein Gehaltsniveau,
unter dem man als Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration nicht einsteigen sollte?
Kommt auf die Region an, kommt drauf an,
was du ...
äh, in welchem Bereich du aktiv bist.
Also, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Ich mein, Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
kann ja von Cloud-Gedöns bis zu Druckerpatronen-Tauschen
alles sein.
Aber ich sag mal, unter 40k würd ich's nicht machen.
Wenn ich jetzt pauschal irgendeine Zahl sagen müsste.
Aber ansonsten ist das schwer zu beantworten jetzt.
Ja, Laravel kenn ich, das war vor ein paar Jahren
schon ziemlich gut und ist wahrscheinlich jetzt noch besser.
PHP ist halt PHP, aber mit Laravel ist es ganz gut.
Symfony, keine Ahnung.
In Virtual Reality und Augmented Reality,
also quasi alles, was wir bisher digital machen,
soll verschmelzen in einer virtuellen Welt.
Und wir haben dabei ein Headset auf,
was uns komplett eintauchen lässt.
Also quasi das Internet in 3D sozusagen.
Und ja, ihr habt das grad richtig gehört.
Leute, ich, ich, ich predikte mal was.
Und ihr wisst, ihr wisst insgeheim, dass ich recht habe.
Ich, ich predikte jetzt mal was.
Sollte wirklich irgendjemand so eine Art, ähm, VR-Chat
Metaverse-technisch starten,
wisst ihr, was der erste Content ist, den es darin geben wird?
Und ihr wisst, dass ich recht hab.
Alles gut, Phipps.
Korrekt.
Das ist das erste, was es geben wird.
Tausendprozentig.
Das ist klar.
Ich meine, man muss sich mal überlegen.
Sei es jetzt VHS-Videotapes oder DVDs oder was auch immer.
Der ganze Kram oder auch VR-Brillen-Gedöns, ja,
das hat sich durchgesetzt zuerst im Porn-Bereich.
Und das ist das erste, was es da geben wird.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt ja
teilweise schon ultra abgedreht.
Wusstet ihr, wusstet ihr,
dass es in Final Fantasy X ist das online, das MMO?
Das war ich auch mal mit dem Friseur eine Weile gespielt habe.
Das ist, dass du dir in Final Fantasy XIV über externe Seiten.
Ja, also ingame gibt es dafür noch keinen Marketplace.
Kannst du dir zum Beispiel
Chat
Chat-Girl Chat-Zeit buchen.
Also da gehst du auf irgendeine Seite, suchst dir was raus, suchst dir das Game aus
und dann kannst du dann buchen mit irgendwer.
Wir müssen nicht Cat-Girls, alles mögliche, was es halt so gibt in Final Fantasy XIV.
Da kannst du dann quasi, nee, nee,
E-Pal, das ist ja noch halbwegs seriös, nennen wir es mal, ja.
Aber da kannst du wirklich dort in-game, erotische in-game Chats buchen in Final Fantasy XIV.
Man sieht schon, die Ansätze sind da.
Und wenn es mal sowas wie Metaverse in der Richtung, wie sie sich das vorstellen, gibt.
Ja, natürlich gibt es das in WoW auch.
Aber ich glaube, dass Final Fantasy XIV durch den Weeb-Faktor noch mal beliebter ist.
Und es ist das klar, dass es das als allererstes gibt.
Arbeit soll auch ein Teil davon sein.
Firmen wie Microsoft und Facebook, aka Meta, denken,
sie haben tatsächlich bald Meetings mit unseren lustigen Avataren in Metaverse.
Danke, dass Sie alle zu den Meetings gekommen sind.
Sie sehen, es sieht aktuell nicht gut aus.
Wir brauchen kreative Ideen.
Johnson, was haben Sie mitgebracht?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Also wie Sie sehen können, haben wir die KPIs in Q2 leider nicht erreicht.
Entschuldigen Sie, Johnson, ich möchte Sie nicht unterbrechen.
Aber ist das ein offizieller Gorilla-NFT aus der Hitler-Kollektion?
Ja, ich dachte, wenn der Chef schon kommt,
dann ziehe ich auch immer einfach das Teuerste an, was ich so habe.
Ich meine, wer hat nicht Bock, nach zwei Jahren Zoom-Meetings bald acht Stunden am
Tag ein schweres Headset aufzuhaben, mit dem man nicht mal richtig zwischendurch
einen Schluck Kaffee trinken kann? Ja, ganz scharf drauf.
Übrigens, Unfälle wegen VR-Headsets sind letztes Jahr...
Die richtig coolen Headsets, die könnten ja dann, die haben noch mal Kamera vorne
drauf, ja, da kannst du dann quasi das Echte noch mal durchsehen oder so.
Um 31 Prozent gestiegen.
Also sprechen wir jetzt mal über all meine Gründe, warum der aktuelle Hype um das
Metaverse meiner Meinung nach richtig dumm ist.
Grund 1, es gibt nicht...
Ich muss, ich muss.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich spüre den Hype um das Metaverse jetzt nicht.
Vielleicht bin ich auch nicht in den passenden
Bubbles unterwegs.
Aber ich merke, ich spüre...
Spürt ihr den Hype ums Metaverse?
Hast du gesehen, wo der Zock in einem Krisengebiet mit seinem Arm hat?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Also ich, ich spüre den Hype um das Metaverse nicht.
Eine Metaverse. Da gibt es Decentraland, wo jemand für 2,4 Millionen ein einziges
Grundstück gekauft hat. The Sandbox, wo jemand 450.000 Dollar
ausgegeben hat, um Snoop Doggs virtueller Nachbar zu werden.
Und wo Adidas...
Ja, wie gesagt, Earth 2 ist auch in der Richtung nicer Scam.
...T-Kleidung verkaufen will.
Wenn euch das wundert, es gibt auch schon digitales Bier und Chicken Wings,
die ich dann anscheinend zusammen mit meinem Furz-NFT genießen kann.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktionieren soll.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch Horizon Worlds von Mark Zuckerberg.
One part of this is Horizon Home.
Und dann noch weniger große Projekte wie
Cryptovoxels, Somnium Space, Nifty Island, Blocktopia oder jetzt bald vermutlich
OTHERSIDE, das Metaverse von Bored Ape.
So was wie VR-Chat gibt es schon ganz
lange und ist auch relativ beliebt seit Jahren schon.
Yacht Club, dem erfolgreichsten NFT überhaupt,
das ist der mit den Schimpansen. Nichts zu verwechseln mit dem mit dem Hitler-Gorilla.
Das Problem ist, die basieren teilweise auch völlig unter...
Die Sache ist halt die,
was ich, was ich halt
bei den Bored Ape
noch nicht mal verstehe, ist.
Die Dinger sehen noch nicht mal gut aus.
Also es ist ja nicht mal, dass ich sagen würde, oh, hier
künstlerisch so toll, das ist randomized aus, keine Ahnung, zwölf verschiedenen
States und also und die Dinger sehen noch nicht mal gut aus.
Nichts zu verwechseln mit dem mit dem Hitler-Gorilla.
Das Problem ist, die basieren teilweise auf völlig unterschiedlichen Technologien.
Bei Horizon Worlds geht es zum
Beispiel bisher gar nicht um NFTs, wie in allen anderen Projekten.
Also wenn Meta hier gewinnt und das Metaverse baut, kann es sein, dass ich
meinen Hitler-Gorilla nie benutzen kann.
Und wenn ich für 450.000 Euro in The Sandbox mein Grundstück habe,
die Centraland aber die führende Plattform wird, habe ich auch.
Korrekt.
Und das nimmt ja schon an, dass sich überhaupt eine durchsetzt in einer Welt,
wo PC, Xbox, PlayStation, Nintendo Switch alle ihre Berechtigung haben, wo ich Zoom,
Google Meet, Discord, Teams, Skype alle gleichzeitig installiert haben muss, weil
jeder irgendwas anderes nutzt.
Wenn ich Metaverse-Fan bin, muss ich vermutlich meine fünf Plattformen am Tag
abklappern und mein teures Grundstück in jeder einzelnen pflegen.
Hier mal Rasen mähen, da die Blumen gießen.
Ich meine, das soll ja auch ein bisschen realistisch sein.
Grund zwei, ein gutes MMO zu bauen, ist verdammt schwierig.
Star Citizen ist ein Weltraum-MMO.
Die Sache ist halt die, was die, glaube ich, alle irgendwie nicht so ganz auf dem Schirm haben.
Zumindest habe ich in der Richtung nichts gesehen.
Warum sollte man in diese Spielwelt gehen?
Ich meine, warum sollte ich in die Spielwelt
gehen, wenn es einfach nur mehr oder weniger genauso lame ist wie die echte Welt?
Also, wo ist der Sinn?
Bei MMO-RPGs, irgendwelchen Fantasy-Dingen oder so, da verstehe ich das.
Da levele ich meinen Charakter, da mache ich irgendwelche Raids, da crafte ich
irgendwas, da erkunde ich die Welt und sonst was.
Das sehe ich bei diesen ganzen Metaverse-Geschichten nicht.
In VR-Chat noch am ehesten, ja,
wobei da, glaube ich, auch User-Generated-Content ganz groß ist.
Also,
ich...
verstehe es nicht so wirklich, ja.
Und das seit über zehn Jahren in Entwicklung ist.
Es hat seitdem über 400 Millionen Dollar gesammelt.
Ungefähr genauso viel Geld wie Yuga Labs,
die Firma hinter dem Metaverse Other Side, dem Bored Ape Yacht Club und CryptoPunks.
Das Ding ist, Star Citizen ist viel weniger aufwendig als ein Metaverse.
Und das kann nicht mal VR.
Und da arbeitet ein Team aus 600 Leuten, die ihre ganze bisherige Karriere lang
Videospiele gebaut haben, seit zehn Jahren dran.
Und das Team ist die Chance relativ groß,
dass Star Citizen niemals wirklich erscheinen wird, wie Star Citizen ist.
Ich glaube, für die meisten Sachen nicht so das beste Beispiel.
Yuga Labs hingegen hat elf Angestellte.
Elf. Und keiner von denen hat, soweit ich weiß, Erfahrung in der Programmierung.
Ja, das ist ja normal.
Die ganzen NFT-Scam-Games werden nie echte Games werden.
Die verkaufen jetzt schon irgendwie so nach dem Motto, jetzt früh sichert euch ganz
schnell irgendwie virtuelles Land, macht hier und da, wenn wir dann releasen,
dann kommt da was.
Aber das ist nie gedacht, was zu releasen.
Das ist gedacht, jetzt Kohle abzugreifen und dann mit der Kohle sich zu verpissen.
Trotzdem hat denen jemand 450 Millionen
Dollar für die Entwicklung eines Videospiels gegeben.
Leute, wisst ihr, wie viele...
Das ist ja, das ist ja einfach zu erklären.
Das erinnert mich an das an das Beispiel
damals aus so 2000 rum zur Dot-Com-Zeit bei der Dot-Com-Bubble.
Da hat ein Bauer, der der Kartoffel angebaut hat, der hat ein
Unternehmen gegründet und hat, der hat dem irgendeinen futuristischen
Dot-Net-Internet-Namen gegeben und die wollten dem Bauer allen Ernstes
Millionen Kapital geben, bis dann irgendwann rauskommen ist, das Typ ist ein
Bauer, der Kartoffeln anbaut, der hat mit Internet und Technologie überhaupt nichts
am Hut und so ähnlich stelle ich mir das da auch vor.
Das wird nicht weiter hinterfragt.
So nach dem Motto, boah, Alter, krass, Metaverse-Shit hier frisst mein Geld, nimm.
Videospiele einfach abgrundtief scheiße
sind und dann auch noch ein MMO, Amazon, der riesige Internetkonzern mit unendlich
vielen Ressourcen, hat letztes Jahr mit New World sein erstes MMO rausgebracht.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass Amazon nicht weiß, was sie machen.
Keine Ahnung, also Amazon, die entwickeln seit Jahren irgendwelche Games, haben kaum
was released, das, was sie released haben, war Schrott.
Und dann kam New World raus, von dem absehbar war, dass es Schrott wird.
Und genau in den
Bereichen Schrott geworden ist, wo man ihm prophezeit hat, dass es Schrott wird.
Ja,
by the way, by the way, Moment mal ne Sekunde, ich hab's doch irgendwo hier.
Wie sieht's aus?
Ah, yes.
Das ist so schlecht, guckt euch das mal an.
20k Peak von 913.000.
...geblich 500 Millionen Dollar pro Jahr,
nicht insgesamt, pro Jahr für Spieleentwicklung aus.
Und was sie damit machen, ist mir unbegreiflich.
Einfach komplett gekreist.
Also was Amazon mit ihrem Geld macht,
ist es mir komplett unverständlich.
Ich weiß einfach vorher selten, ob ein MMO langfristig erfolgreich ist.
Und trotzdem geben Leute Millionen von Dollar aus für Gegenstände in Spielen,
die es noch nicht mal wirklich gibt.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal die Grafik an von Decentraland.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass viele das machen, weil sie hoffen.
Also nicht, weil sie wirklich an das Spiel glauben oder so.
Die hoffen, dass sie das noch teurer
verkaufen können und sich dann wieder vom Acker machen.
Was anderes kann.
Wer glaubt denn ernsthaft daran, dass aus diesen ganzen NFT-Krypto-Games
irgendwann mal ein spielenswertes Game wird?
Es ist eher umgedreht.
Sobald ein Game anfängt, was von NFT und Krypto-Kram zu erzählen,
gehe ich eher davon aus, dass das Game nie ein gescheites Game wird.
Also es ist genau umgedreht.
Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt einer sagt NFT-Krypto und ich sag, boah, cooles Game,
sondern eher ich sag vielleicht, oh, cooles Game.
Und dann sagt der NFT-Krypto und ich sag, okay, und tschüss.
Das ist ein Bild.
Das ist...
Das haben die selbst gepostet.
Das sieht, das sieht aus, das sieht aus wie Wii-Avatare oder Xbox 360-Avatare.
Nur in schlecht.
Das ist, das ist ihr bester Eindruck, den sie machen konnten.
Das hier ist ein offizielles Video von Meta, von deren Website.
My Avatar is able to look the way I feel inside.
Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du bist in einem Meeting, was so aussieht.
Und falls ihr euch gerade fragt so, hä?
Das sieht doch einfach aus wie ein 20 Jahre altes Computerspiel.
Das sieht aus wie Sims, nur in schlecht.
Was ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied?
Es gibt keinen, außer dass Computerspiele tatsächlich eine Story haben und coole
Quests, mit denen man Abenteuer erleben kann.
Nichts hat jemals irgendjemanden davon
abgehalten, ein Business-Meeting in World of Warcraft zu veranstalten.
Es ist halt einfach nur eine dumme Idee.
Grund drei, deine NFT-Items wird es nie geben.
Warum? Ich fand das nice.
Ich mache mir die ganze Zeit Witze über den Hitler-Gorilla fürs Metaverse, weil
das einfach lächerlich ist.
Aber auch bei anderen Items stellt sich ja die Frage, wenn ich jetzt einem NFT-Projekt
sehr viel Geld gebe für ein Bild in der Blockchain, dann hat diese Person...
Das Bild ist ja noch nicht mal in der Blockchain.
Die das gemacht hat, ja schon all mein Geld, aber hatte bisher lächerlich wenig Arbeit.
Die musste nur ein JPEG malen.
Dieses JPEG dann später aber in 3D zu modellieren, das zu riggen, dann die Blockchain in das Metaverse
meiner Wahl zu integrieren, obwohl es da vielleicht gar keine Schnittstelle gibt und das dann
regelmäßig mit Updates zu versorgen, weil das Metaverse ja auch immer wieder geupdatet wird.
Das kostet unglaublich viele Ressourcen.
Aber ich habe ja schon alles dafür bezahlt.
Also welche Motivation sollte irgendjemand haben?
Diese Metaverse-Ready-Items?
Nee, die nicht.
Die haben eher Interesse daran, ihren eigenen Shit zu verkaufen.
Auch tatsächlich herzustellen, nachdem er schon durch mich Multimillionär geworden ist.
Mal abgesehen davon, dass die Leute, die
aktuell die ganzen NFTs anbieten, meistens gar keine Programmierer sind.
Und mal abgesehen davon, ob jemand
die Meta einen Hitler-Gorilla zulassen würde.
Obwohl...
Vielleicht ist die Animation dann noch ein extra, quasi ein DLC-NFT.
...ausmacht. Rechtsextreme Affen.
Grund 4. Das Metaverse ist eine dystopische Horrorwelt, in der keiner leben will.
Das Metaverse will nicht nur unser Social Media sein, sondern auch unsere Spiele,
unser Entertainment, unsere Meetings...
Also quasi Roblox.
Es gibt ein riesen Problem damit, wenn
unser gesamtes Leben von einer einzigen Plattform abhängt.
Und nochmal extra
wenn dann dahinter irgend so was seltsames wie NFTs oder Kryptos steckt und alles zu
Geld gemacht werden soll. Mal abgesehen davon, dass ein Metaverse, was tatsächlich
geil ist, auch super gefährlich wäre, weil Leute dann kein echtes Leben mehr leben wollen.
Social Media...
Da müssen wir uns keine Gedanken zu machen.
Und dann haben wir auch noch Mark Zuckerberg.
Da müssen wir uns, glaube ich, wenig Gedanken zu machen.
Das haben wir... Was weiß ich.
Das wird ja immer wieder prophezeit, auch bei MMOs.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, es wird kein Metaverse geben, wo die Leute 24 7 drin sein wollen.
...
...als perfekten Sci-Fi-Bösewicht.
Not everyone wants their social media
profile linked to all these other experiences and I get that.
Und das Internet...
Ja, I get that.
Deswegen macht's mit eurem Facebook-Account.
Bringt schon jetzt das Schlimmste in unserer Gesellschaft ans Tageslicht.
Horizon Worlds ist noch nicht mal wirklich draußen.
Und schon jetzt gab es Fälle, wo Frauen digital befummelt wurden.
Das ist kein Witz.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Das ist so oft passiert in Horizon Worlds, gibt's deswegen inzwischen eine Armlänge Abstand.
Okay, also ist das Metaverse Bullshit?
Das ist... Oh Mann.
Ich, und das überrascht euch jetzt vielleicht, liebe VR.
Ich zweifle echt an der gesamten Menschheit langsam.
Ich habe eine Menge Spaß mit der Oculus bzw.
der Meta-Quest, aber nicht für mehr als eine Stunde immer mal wieder.
Ich bin aber offen dafür, zu sehen, wo die Technologie hingeht.
Und ich freue mich auch drauf, weil ich finde es ziemlich krass, was schon möglich ist.
Aber als jemand, der ein VR-Headset zu Hause hat und seit 20 Jahren als einziges Hobby Videospiele spielt, weiß ich, wenn das
Metaverse kommt, dann sind wir noch Jahre davon entfernt.
Leute, die jetzt investieren, sind viel zu früh.
Vor 20 Jahren in der Dotcom-Blase haben
Leute auch festgestellt, korrekt, dass das Internet das nächste größte Ding ist.
Und dann haben sie alle in die dümmsten Firmen investiert und alle Geld verloren.
Ja, zum Beispiel Bauern mit Kartoffeln.
Und ja, auch das Metaverse.
Da sind für mich überall Visionen drin.
PC kann ich dir gleich zeigen.
Und etwas, was tatsächlich Sinn machen könnte und auch sehr cool sein könnte.
Könnte. Noch gibt es das nicht.
Die ersten Visionen, die es gibt, sind absolut schrecklich.
Noch ist das überhaupt nicht cool.
Kleiner Fun Fact am Rande.
1929 hat der Vater von John F. Kennedy angeblich den größten Börsen-Crash der
Geschichte vorhersagen können, weil ein Junge, der ihm die Schuhe poliert hat,
angefangen hat, ihm Aktientipps zu geben und das für ihn ein absolut klares Zeichen war,
dass hier Leute am spekulieren waren, die absolut keine Ahnung von Finanzmärkten
hatten und er hat daraufhin all seine Aktien verkauft und den Crash überlebt.
Wenn wir das jetzt 100 Jahre später über...
Naja, gut.
Also jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Irgendeine Anekdote, wo irgendeiner mal was
Richtiges gemacht hat und Millionen Leute, die es falsch gemacht haben.
Also das kann ja alle mögliche.
Es kann im Endeffekt einfach nur Glück gewesen sein.
Wer sich einen Hitler-Gorilla kauft in der
Hoffnung, dass er den mal als Kostüm in einem neuen 3D-Facebook anziehen kann, was
es noch gar nicht gibt, von dem würde ich keine Finanztipps annehmen und vielleicht
auch generell gar keine Tipps, weil das wäre eine absolut schreckliche Welt.
Finanztipps solltet ihr von mir annehmen.
Im letzten Monat minus
577 Euro und 69 Cent.
Da kannst du eigentlich nichts besseres machen mehr.
Stonks, ja.
Massive Stonks.
Zeitdepot, nö.
Da gibt es nicht viel zu zeigen.
Wie geht es den Amazon-Aktien?
Hat sie nicht viel getan?
Es ist immer noch ähnlich zu dem, wo ich es gekauft habe.
Das ist minimal hoch, aber nicht viel.
Und ich habe Hunger.
Ich bin drei Stunden 33 schon on.
Das ist ja für meine Verhältnisse schon ziemlich lang.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die können acht Stunden am Tag streamen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ich wäre heiser, wenn ich mehrfach die Woche acht Stunden streamen würde.
Sando, danke für den Sub.
Abo-Falle zugeschnappt.
So, YouTube, letzte Chance, uns was zu empfehlen, was ich unbedingt sehen will.
Nope.
Kondome durchlöchert.
Moment, was für ein Ding?
Reverse Stealthing.
Was für ein Ding?
Okay, für was es nicht alles Wörter gibt.
Neuestes Video verlohnt sich das.
Das heben wir uns für irgendwie einen der nächsten Tage auf.
Da ist bestimmt auch wieder was, wo ich am
Ende streamt, ein paar Runden Videos gucke, so zum Ausklang.
Da gucken wir uns das dann an.
Ich schaue mal schnell, ob wir irgendjemand raiden können.
Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis zum nächsten Stream. Macht's gut.
See you.